hmmm ça luc absolue à tous donc fab
on est on est de retour pour un très
beau match ce soir ouais ouais ouais
donc que vonn forest contre louis
joueurs chinois donc il va être favori
mais attention à sa connexion
voilà c'est quand même c'est sûr est
comme une blessure tu es c'est comme
s'il y avait un petit problème au mollet
bon match précédent 5,7 et une petite
alerte au mollet voilà c'est ça la
connexion quoi nous sommes présents là
des femmes font attention magie n'est
pas connectée donc j'ai envie de te dire
comment vas tu jouais quoi attendre faut
que je passe le sting sur la chaîne
blisstree m'attend et que j'ouvre le
chat aussi la wii petit dans le tchat
ivo karlovic comme ça je suis là pour le
chat
aulas chicos l'as los chicos ballet qui
l'écrit aulas chicos tougourt highway
mais il s'est fait éliminer mais il a
passé revient c'est fort est un peu
juste non il a perdu contre un italien
ont complètement nulle où paris compte
fabiano je crois oui oui oui votre
trouble sting donc la question assez
génial tu as vu leurs tweets que j'ai
fait de vendre forest avec son frère
mais il est sorti de la fin c'était très
fort enfin lui cache des trolls et j'ai
trop les quoi oui j'ai trop laid le
le compte de chartres aussi ce matin qui
sommes super france à chartres 2019
déchets du début bonne forest joppy deux
oueds japy doigts est ce que c'est ce
que c'est joppy d'air bassam jobijoba
avec dp quoi il se trouve qu'il ya il ya
une il ya une friterie hollandaise à
côté de chez moi je belge occupe alors
il se trouve qu'à s'appelle amsterdam
mais en fait c'est une sauce pour avec
les frites le soc plus maillot puis
sketchup jusqu'où c'est un mélange
j'aurais dit maillot curie s'est passé
mais c'est très bon en fait c'est enfin
quand tu viendras du coup on ira c'est
un peu comme les bras bourse tu as je
sais pas ce que c'est le rembourser les
saucisses allemandes très bon je crois
surtout la traditionnelle cage à
hambourg est réservé aux anges en tout
cas on peut prendre le jaudy avec une
sauce avait avec une saucisse en fait
mais c'est un peu seuls des liens donc
bah quand tu viens on ira du très
intéressant ça on voit très intéressant
les en fait les frites sont minutées
maison et donc c'est enfin c'est
forcément très intéressant de tu peux te
prendre un cornet de frites aller sur la
plage ou quoi le soir tu assez bien avec
du shopi pas rater pas obligés du grand
duc et ufa tu fais ce que tu veux en
fait assez bien quand on aime on fera un
tweet
j'ai pris des frites vente fort est bien
on le fait quand on se chauffe pour le
troll en fait c'est génial non mais
chartres comment j'étais trop laid mais
aussi parce qu'ils te recommande de
rester à paris pour jouer des tournois
ah oui parce que pour parce que le métro
coupe la chasse à l'homme
ouais mais enfin l'impact carbone quoi
enfin la même chance pas de chance mais
bon tâche d'eric cumul j'ai rien
championnat de france féminin et impact
carbone quand je leur gouvernement mais
bon alors jetez plus tard quand même pas
chercher les fautes 3 quoi il voguera
ischémie on vous entendre on ne vous
voit pas
ouais mais pas la paix on laisse on
laisse les infos ont fait exprès il ya
un peu les ya un peu les infos les
horaires changent en train de regarder
le 7 juillet à 20 heures
ah ouais c'est fou quand l'action crit
blé dur à sera le 16 c'est à dire dont
six jours c'est d'abord de commenter
après le le grand prix quoi mais ce que
j'ai c'est exactement ce que j'étais en
train de me dire j'étais en train
exactement de penser à ça et je me
disais
[Musique]
je me disais rien fait pour moi pas de
chance pour ce match là alors réservez
oui l'arrivée c'est un sentiment avec
connexion et en sueur ou s'abattant
ayela mais vend deux fois récemment du
coup il y ait plus la fraîcheur et qui
se barre ils vont jour environ 10
minutes à wailly se re barre en fin de
course au bâton qu'est-ce qu'on s'attend
à un match serré baffe le monde disait
ça dépend de la connexion wi fi dans mon
cas mais il est au dessu brooks après je
pense que ce qu ils égaux 2819 sûr tu as
comme saint-pierre à peu près mon vélo
tu vas y a que 20 points de plus que moi
est-ce qu'il en sûrs par m puisque le
trio short qui court à côté mais que je
dis oui c'est un manque de respect pour
saimone williams
1 pourquoi qui barèges pas fin au
contraire c'était un hommage trouvait
face au bord de la route a crié tout ça
c'est beau non même pas c'est un hommage
à simone au contraire ben moi je sais ce
que l'art sur l'aviateur c'est quand
même un eric en scène fantastique avec
brio dans des tubes qui font des rondes
ici c'est génial ben oui c'est parce
qu'il fait dans sa tête il pour que mon
bien en fait aya short est tous très
heureux aussi phase extraordinaire
moi j'aime bien hikaru avec un gros
sourire devant qui roule ou est ce les
sauts très heureux aussi derrière dans
la roue quoi je te montre tout tout tout
le reste sur wes et je suis en train de
me faire lâcher car culte merde que
c'est que tu vois en plus sur la photo a
déjà perdu dit m enfin c'est fini quoi
je ne reviens plus quoi tu as fait
l'élastique de pénétrer en liga c'est
quoi avec la goutte de sueur par aof
ça fait marrer si jamais tu as des idées
de miniature où je suis en sueur
n'hésitent pas à passer l'idée c'est
qu'à chaque fois je sois choix mal
copains c'est tellement drôle en fait
mettre dans des situations où je suis je
suis mal quoi donc le match qu'on pense
pas ben on ne sait pas si ça laisse à
penser à cette partie et on arrive à la
première info connexion il a envoyé à
une mauvaise connexion mais le baril
atteint
il suffit d'un petit coup de vent il
passe à une cuisse et des collecteurs
attention bon que ben hur intel d'accord
donc en fait je pense vendre forez
favori du coût de la connexion
non mais on est des fins analystes par
ci prend des cinq si tu veux trop long
ça se joue n'importe quel projet 5 qui
fâchent patoijeux 4 c'est plus normal
le genre de truc où les nord 1 1 pions
et s'approche un peu parfois aussi aux
cheveux quoi ils s'accrochent à fond il
s'accroche à son pion qua non
il soumet réveillant sur pareil dans les
roues quoi il fait ce qu'il peut
je tiens mon option en fait voilà une
miniature après chaque partie qui résume
la partie qui l'accroché comment abordes
après un prime c'est ça ouais non merci
je passais un genre de mission
impossible
c'est appris en avion il s'accroche
parfois aux dents dans les îles se met
souvent dans les trains d'atterrissage
là et ils m'ont aussi en train
d'atterrissage à fond donc
et là tu peux pas récupérer ps est bas
peut-être pas tu prendrais pas sûr on ne
poserai la question ne peut pas dire
parce qu'il arrive à roque est sûrement
une dernière tâche j'aurais pas réfléchi
très longtemps comme nous dre prix bas
c'est gratuit non ouais mais rock
taperont à berck et 6,5 pour tenir sur
chirac fedama 600 red wings ce week-end
qui suit à trois mois la très bien mais
le calibre venir sur henri iv ou ont des
3t changer ta paire de foot je sais pas
je passe est très grave
tu vas prendre le set peut-être que
c'est juste perdant et g5 des 5 4 h 10 -
ok ça se trouve c'est juste hyper
théorique stars sont un truc juste ok
peut-être kf3 le retour à quai h 3à
c'est pas bête
je reviens pas mal 4 pour moi je préfère
les blancs mais les blancs sont liées à
la non bah je dirais ça maintenant que
je le redis plus puissant en fait tu
peut allumer enfin là dessus je suis un
ordi super pi sont je peux regarder
alors dit tu te dis ces cinq grands
avantages noir la dégage non je vais il
te faisais ces 500 voiliers le fou rire
décathlon et objets d'art à 5
ça ne m'intéressait pas du tout en fait
tu faisais d'aller de il faisait quoi il
faisait cavalier b6 en fait c'est une
appli ne te propres déjà là en d4 cette
fois et dès maintenant imagine kh3
français arrivent en italie les flancs
sont bien mais attention connexion rouge
feu chez oui et c'est génial ça variance
quand même chez moi georges blessés 5
voitures grand dessein que vous pensez
des hausses et prend des cadres en fait
non damas 5 et b6 c'est génial j'adore
leur vie en fait il bon de remettre je
change de chemise ni ça fait très mal
aux yeux ma chemise non c'est l'été
chemise hawaïenne de hawaïen d'ailleurs
de take mais je suis amusé tahitienne
voilà juste additionné donc tu aimais
six four b3 ouaip d'amd a pu jouer un
coup mais je pense qu'ils jouent vite et
bien d'autres en fait je voudrais bien
faire flouer 5 et master sur la caste et
4 pour la v5 quand même te prendre pour
preuve cette découverte
dommage une et seule chance a fait 17
morts qui m'aide à me dit ah ok vous
faire [ __ ] en f3 et peut-être même pas
si grave tu peux te faire f 4 juste en
fait oui je me demandais du roi a chargé
un partout c'est ça ouais ouais c'est
très dans l'esprit 1 seront très bien
mais c'est génial d'être en équilibre
grâce ni quoi je paye l'abonnement
geoffroy guichard à table si oui plus
expressif que le fil rogers nakamura
d'hyères c'est quoi ce fear ou janet le
mois ouais si roger un témoin avait ni
une adoption mais non mais en fait le
problème c'est que enfin le prénom se
connaître on a découvert que fier route
j'ai écouté du haryana camurat adacore
part on l'a découvert fin c'est nous qui
avons 10 à face et une info qu'on a
lâché en fait on a dernièrement fait il
changé et du coup comme la chanson de
diana corps un haka murat qui s'appelle
le jah jah du court la bête firoud déjà
jack john cena camurat les menaces de
mort enfin tu as passé
c'est un mélange de tout après s'être
moqué d'un bien te plaît parce qu'en
fait je le sais mais karoubi karakama me
lasser for the sun tu as forcément un
mec dans le tchat sur wii c'est quoi ces
histoires que ces histoires
oui car oui la scène mort belle à la
vidéo a été supprimée il a supprimé la
vidéo de 2 de sa chaîne donc ça prouve
quand même le no fake
ben oui quelques parfums cher ça ça
prouve qu'il n'assume pas ses menaces
quoi donc mon body string
batista goûte un très fort joueur mais
il peut que te permettrai de locaux n'y
a pas tués cette année assez tôt en
début d'année bon donc
mais en fait j'aime bien les noirs
maintenant bah oui bombe une partie à
rebondissements
tyson tâche s'il ya plus de preuves a du
coup ça prouve le dos fake c'est
extraordinaire oui ça suffit les flux
preuve c'est d'ailleurs troublant ouais
c'est ce que trouble encore ok donc
d'ailleurs fait super mal mais en fait
chez le why i c'est pas possible il ya
déjà le match précédent il a super mal
joué la jambe il a sué pour battre
double allende
mais fâchent parce que je suis à maxime
face est pas possible le mec c'est
failli quand même top 20 mondial il te
fait les grandes chaînes ce tour rapide
et blitz il est bon enfin je l'aï peut
pas être moins fort que vente forest
gérer un problème ou être à notre club
sportif du match ou non mais j'en
normalement il ya juste le raser nos wii
wii béjart il est beaucoup plus fort
ouais bon mais ça se trouve il va te
prendre mais ça doit faire ses 6 et 7 6
8 puis voilà c'est vrai que ça c'est
efficace mais bon peut-être fois ci soit
tu reviens n'y joue à si vite en fait
bail mais oui une mauvaise connexion ici
donc y obliger ça me fait tellement rire
que la connexion sociale forfait
bah oui mais l'important c'est le seul
espoir qu'on croise mais la clé comme ça
que
que green a perdu le match c'est comme
si tu avais un match de tennis quoi je
pense c'est federer la comptine chic
auris et oui si le corps d'un acheteur
te federer commence et c'est beaucoup
quoi c'est comme s'ils voulaient pas
changer de raquette
n'at-il pas 4g pas en vélo tu crèves
enfin pas de chance il a déraillé quoi
bref pour chaussures
c'est pourquoi patch de foot à des
problèmes de crampons il commence à
pleuvoir mais 15e plus trop de boue tu
prend de vitesse de partout c'est
vraiment extra j'adore en fait ça me
rend tellement heureux alors bon des
couteaux reprends ton c4 j'imagine
j'aurais pu tomber ça fonctionne mais
c'est parce que au fond assez mais ça va
être nul en bantoustans inquiet je pense
mais le pion à 5
la tour ans et 8 le fou en b 4 mais
quoique noah 11 pts 6 le hsv gatz pas
bête
l'autre option c'est de faire du tour de
battre la c6 bon peloton c'était manger
c'est toujours un bon j'ai en fait tu
peut le chasser leurs fouets f 4 et 5 tu
peux le dégager de cette diagonale pour
pas qu'ils puissent soutenir
l'occurrence c'est cette peur venir en
août roy bbc
c'est pas faux mais peut-être chez le
temps de mettre le mien en a3 du coup
georges suis-je et 5 mai il faut trois à
quatre litres en attend au moins tu as
tout dit si ce petit jeu c'est pas des
six tours à six ne sais pas si notre
décision mais si sa mairesse tu fais à 4
tours prend rien je vais montrer ventes
à 4 tours prend tous ses sept tours
c'est l'âge c'est pas de chance mais là
du coup ils verront bien les plus
longues même attendre peut-être 3 et 6
si ce varois réussissent tu te ramène
l'équipe du jour bilans et roger deux
ont valu une autre côté quel final doit
être gagnant tout j'ai le temps de faire
un mur parce que lorsqu'il fait froid f3
je fais cinq faits a dirigé quatre
égyptiens déjà pas mal d'élus du mur
mais bon 4 un petit h3t ben achour h5
web où fut v6 3 17 tours h5 3,7 à 4,5
j'écarte très bien joué affolée gens
noté g4 prenez un petit calepin vous
noté beaucoup manqué il va taper h5
ok donc défini les nuls mais il raconté
lâche 4 vous allez prendre à gauche
maintenant c'est être un peu plus venir
maintenant c'est bien de désintérêt sont
plus fatigués et tout beau serge est
l'option g4 fait ben ouais ça aurait été
plus venimeux mais après je pense était
quand même nul mais plus venimeux
certains voient comme un corps au dos
sans leur venin c'est un peu comme un
dragon de komodo le plus rage 4 ouais il
est là il n'avance pas mais enfin je
voudrais c'est que quitte à bord du quoi
c'est fini
ouais mais cette finale aller nul mais
bon je vous pas laissé de chance à
roissy ce g5 lahitète g5 déjà c'est
peut-être déjà plus d'une sur les ok
peut-être que ce métier tu as des échecs
un peu bon droit se marient vers le
centre en fait je pense c'était bien de
laisser la tour on peut se marrer vers
ie8 en fait ouais c'est ça la tour en
bref c'était pas mal cette année jamais
g5 way taxe bike ne le sait que sur race
et satya tour g1 ok la tour g1 roi ouais
ça j'aime pas une tour à tour jusqu'à
maintenant aux rois et le roi des mines
on voit des huit bombes et demi tour
mais vont redevenir intéressant
peut-être bon ok il
il l'est puisque c'est génial mais
technique d'épuisement on ruine tour
cette façon il va faire mais si j'arrive
à utiliser quoi et tours 7
ai-je demandé justice au prochain en
fait celui-ci a fait avec les noirs
faille tu as fait des échecs partout et
on me fait passer au riz blanc ce qu'il
a fait
ou c'est moi mais je pense que ce final
elle est analysée dans le lit de kerrest
callaway mais je pense aller c'est une
finale assez connue non un homme aurait
trop juste pas laisser les deux options
se mettre côte à côte le coup mais une
fois que ce tango dakota tu peux
vraiment perdre parce que déjà perdu en
mer mais c'est bizarre qu'on l'a laissé
monter les plus trop le temps il va
faire un coup comme f6 un moment donné
jean paul jaud ff7 genre tu te déplaces
un petit f 6 je sais pas ce qui est des
pages inclut sur la septième est
peut-être fait le 3 juin paraissent pas
facile c'est pas facile
c'est quoi ce tour ou alors peut-être
maintenant qu'un expert du pew zone je
suis pas un expert du tout c'est à dire
moi je suis fait des vidéos
enfin mais je t'ai envoyé là en fait je
t'envoie suis élu je vais te demande mj
oui où vous voudrez hors stream
pour qu'on le pense non mais t'as le
droit mais non en fait j'ai refait fait
le truc fâche s'expliquer rapidement
juste bon comme la parvenir si j'ai
refait le montage d'eau de vidéos en
fait de dvd bien qu en fait ça me
saoulait de tout re regarder parce que
moi j'ai fait déjà les trucs et je vais
voir te ramènera je te fasse un retour
ouais mais en fait faut juste que juste
et début de vidéo les fins de vidéos
juste pour voir c'est bien clean nova de
vie toute façon d'aller regarder
oui notre nom donc je me suis je peux te
les envoyer de décoffrage chemin
séparant brut de décoffrage brute de
décoffrage en fait tu les as passé déjà
à couper quand même plus ou moins est
juste le juridisme depuis une année
d'une part tous deux n'étaient pas
bonnes ouais ouais faut que je sens mais
ça en fait je me verrai tout à la fin
nathan donc votre botte secrète j'ai
peut-être changer les comment comment
les années sont montrés là j'ai fait un
truc un peu tu vois rudimentaire j'ai
bien mieux le faire donc on va tuer tout
changer mon dieu mes meilleurs c'est
très intéressant comme un chapitre
surtout la nuit
la deuxième partie du chapitre 2
d'ailleurs va te plaire
ok maintenant je ne dis pas ce que c'est
mais tu va rigoler je vais être mort de
rire ça tient pas nos objectifs on se
plaît tu écris d'être fait des très
bonnes méthodes médecine sais pas je te
connais pas le fond de la cour sur la
cia branger pas de chance alors que ça
fait pas très bon début de semaine
l'intégration du pouvoir essaie de faire
des inside job dans tes propres tricot
bon alors du coup cette partie donc le
pion isolé mais là ça paraît bien pour
les noirs faty aucune à la motte et
projets au dessus tuant six graves et ie
7 et un coup ici bah ouais je me base je
sais pas pourquoi le cavalier il était
obligatoire au parti à tours à des huit
qui va arriver des six tours dès 8 ans
fait pète mans mais la poutre faire des
cinq ans fait un bain se dit bien alors
des cinq temps d'éviter ce que fais tu
fais pas des cinq titres en tour des
huit tours des six tours david c'est
fini c'est fini
non mais
tu n'auras n'en es tu ne vas jamais un
gros qu'une attaque sur le roi at-on fou
et en f1 une âme à [ __ ] cases noires
vas tu vaux h trois fois je sais pas
j'étais chargé car comprend que
peut-être seul centre oui enfin
déjà je me demande pour réparer non mais
toi et ça c'est bien carrillo 5 le faire
quoi il veut juste faire tout reprend
des cartes en fait sur caillou 5 et la
tour prends des 4 enfin il est très très
mal lotis bah je sais pas mais dont je
n'ai pas ce plus isolé déjà été changés
un fou il vous tarde pas à faire des
sympathies rien fait tu as juste les
défauts du pion sans le maintien de ce
mal non non plus tu mets le fond f1
d'ailleurs le poulet il appartient à la
caste b1 le plus embêté roi aussi très
mal placé quant à l'option b de a3 à ba2
wifi l'option ya jojo qui te demandait
sur un ordi sans lecteur dvd ce lhc d y
at il une version numérique non non mais
j'ai envie d'avoir une version du sdk
être que c'est le patron c'est d'abord
son ballon rien n'est finalisé
tu ne pourra être fait qu'à terme et
renforcer raconte que vous faites
peut-être qu'on a raté un truc vite
qu'avant à vii est en train de me dire
ouais on va prendre un dossier sur la
fuite et à rien tu penses la raison le
problème fin ouais c'est un peu chanceux
ça c'est le parquet lieu de chemises
rouges ont tout d'abord franck le père
est parce que là le cari protège plus la
tour d vite comme ça sur tour des indes
abc ce pays n'a pas à temps plein mais
l'état sont ils avaient troqué son
entrée dans l'ère leproux baissa de
quitter ce titre et peut assez fou en
fait ça marchait pas tant 17
c'est fou ainsi vos qui rate ça quand
même
naïf et paca value 2
fabre s'amarrer sert de ce fait en pls
ah ben je sais pas vous mais je sais pas
qu'est-ce qu'on rate encore et des bas
mais s'attend à temps je m l'ordi j'ai
pas compris
sinon dame prend il faut faire tourner
un ok peut-être qu'il veut gagner
différemment à turpan des quatre fils
numéro un il y aurait lieu de gagner
aussi métro prend des calmants des
quatre bons rails et il prenait juste
son temps pour bien bien finir bien
comme il faut à la brochette en croit
bon j'attends croit boost ou bien il a
bien joué là franchement c'est bien là
ce qu'il a fait beaucoup trop fraîche
bon le truc j'ai pas trouvé la partie
bien construite quoi mais ok déjà bien
pour l'intérêt du match 6 pour revenir
place normalement ils savent aller quoi
il voulait plus fin voici les noirs il
arrive à stabiliser genre faisait tomber
cette tour 17 chez parce qu'on gagne
mais qui en dessin qui fait des trucs
chiants mais là bon vous tapez encore il
va te faire rage si sa cavalcade qui est
fait chevalier
oui il va devoir mais bon on va rentrer
ou pas celle d'un coup ils iraient de
fer g6 je pense je sais j'ai six leurs
effets plutôt et au pire on va faire
rage de ceux des clous point f1 on prend
ces 6 tu prends avec deux bravo mais bon
peu à quatre on pousse à fond
franchement c'est très simple à gagner
est bon mais tu vois ça m'étonne un peu
un mec du niveau de wailly tu vois c'est
pas possible tu veux aussi mal
mike lenhoff le tout c'est pas lui cinq
titulaires qui le souhaitent à se
résigner ou quoi fasse vrai qu'il n'est
pas très expressif en tout cas mais je
suis étonné du niveau de loyer en fait
dans ce match s
pas des assistants passer au dessus de
la mêlée comme on l'a remarqué mais il
doit être mis sous la dent mais il est
plus fort que fit route a encore un fois
faire foirer t on enfin fil rouge est
très fort j'aime bien et tout mais j'ai
heureusement les paquets de 4,6 en feu
ben je crois qu'il veut faire de leurs
oiseaux j'imagine ouais mais qui est pro
f 2 du coup oui mais rien wen ont même
quelqu'un c'est un peu risqué pour rien
imerys a et a pas qu'un tas paquet ici
cinq ski adam françaises' sanomat c'est
pas de chance mais bon je sais pas quand
elle rompt h2 qui est pro f 2 il peut un
pion h4
après la dame elle est forte quand même
n'y a rien fait je pense y revenir
il y aura rien en non piquée preuve de
bon tu comptes jusqu'à 5 on enlève la
dame est assise et nous avons bon j
aurais gagné le premier set les les amis
bon après plus tueur à avoir des idées
de forteresse un moment donné avec les
pions je sais pas parce qu'en fait tu te
retrouves avec 6,1 et a réussi à
échanger genre le fou contre le pion et
cavaliers coach le fouet
le guide un second tour et que des bons
films de genre stade pour en être sain
qu'un pion h5 du défunt voilà mille pion
à 6 j'aurais peut-être fait f5 avec les
noirs pour pouvoir mettre le roi bref
dans h 7 4 je pensais bien je sais que
tu as taf quatre points assez
m'attendais quand même est-ce qu'on tue
par le matador baies vitrées de hockey
tu es tu fais
qu'est-ce après revue j'aime pas du tout
mais bon tu essayais pas de choix note
florent va jusqu'où un truc and more to
way est un guerrier cabinet sur blanc il
attaquera des cases vrai mais il lui
manquait un temps en fait il aurait eu
le temps d'un peut cacher son roi et de
faire être 4 et tous auraient pu être
hyper dangereux dès qu'il peut être
juste dame b 8 prend des cinq épreuves
pendant que le roi qui a sept à huit
je pense oui le truc c'est que si
l'autre ils pouvaient fin si oui vous
avez sacrifié le par à jouer ça il va
avoir deux dames
ça c'est fort de dames mais bon je ne
sais pas d'où tu es chez toi tu rates
cgr il te laisse les deux dames qui
n'est pas ça la force qu un scan dame
gilles d'am-dam g8 et dan 1,8 après la
nomme ça c'est fort et roquefort qui est
le quatrième à vis à vis 6 quoi ils
défendent partout et il aurait pu on
peut jouer encore pas tout est défendue
et tu te bats n'en est pas là pour les
embêter greenstock fils adam sur
n'importe quoi saturne énorme avantage
mondiaux jem brillante ouais y rejouer
accroche ou pas mais ok il faut voir
qu'il y avait ces cinq était intéressant
mais l'on nie d'abord devant le check up
au moins quelqu'un lui a remis un texte
ouvre les parties jamais réussi à
comprendre si c'était légal ou pas dans
ce truc là de recevoir d'extraction
entre les parties bah moi je fais un
dessin en fait mais je dirais que oui
maman ici en fait dirais que oui
je vois pas pourquoi en fait tu n'aurais
pas le droit entre les partis interdits
que c'est dû à posteriori c'est pas en
te dis oui il faut jouer thème coup sans
te diras tu as raté ça où tu ne te
souviens plus machin voit la tulipe à
des fichiers dégage non mais oui mais
c'est surtout que rien ne dit que la
pression va réapparaître plus tard non
mais c'est comme ça franchement on parle
au tennis de fer intervention du coach
pour le match ou des choses comme ça pas
même au foot et demi tandis que chez
roth par léger défaut chez le droit non
t'as pas le droit non paris non bien sûr
je vais strike d'ailleurs donc faire y
avoir quatre quatre des cinq têtes
ouais sur le même thème et donc oui la
part dieu ait son âme bien et compagnie
les têtes ya reçu un sms en chinois à se
récuser droit de recevoir des textos
mais que dans une langue que tu ne
comprends pas que tu vas battre à fond
pour le lire donc tu t'es des deux
peut-être troupes et un tour b 5 est ce
que c'est un peu être un plan ça moi tu
vas nous au moins on sait cinq ans c'est
un petit air de colmar les courants
j'ai pas mal à colmar ce week end
bagdad alors à colmar alors ouais
beaucoup de fautes cinq petites clouage
pas mal de ne plus tôt pas trop mal les
noirs un première vue mais bon je suis
pas expert des trucs pourquoi pas chez
quatre voies la céramique te dire voilà
g4 donc le fonds voit reculer
ouais mais peut-être en 17 pour attaquer
machin est en tête 5 éxacte fou ses six
essais 6 mais bon après tu commencé aux
quatre machines
le quatre des cinq voyages avance dur à
dire
voilà déjà repoussé et vite on peut
perdre de temps ils sont fous bombattak
rien mais on ne s'attaque pas non plus
quoi voilà que tu as perdu f5 mon truc
pour les oies droite au kenya crémant
prix elle a carrément ça c'est vrai que
j'ai même pas regarder c'est pas bête tu
manges un tournoi ce qui est bon c'est
trois fraîcheur mais qu'est ce que
france 4 et france et trois dames
franges et 6
car il y prend d un may a rien derrière
page c'est calculé truc un peu marrant
quoi may hamm et du cou à des blancs et
un peu nigel du court ouais ben harper
n'a it up
bon on a maintenant tu as le choix que
tu vas devoir faire un truc sur cet os
et quatre blessés naturex faut essayer
d'en perdre qu'un faisons garde qu'un et
le moins grave possible mais peut-être
les 5 malgré la peur de perdre et en
fait on en train de te perdre la femme
ah bon ouais
donc c'est d'arranger donc je peux je
vais voir ça mieux on te retrouve là
alors si tu fais avère fois deux accusés
de garder la menace d'un projet 6 et la
dame pranger 6e peut-être parce que des
fois m6 après et d'un match 5
ok d'instinct qui sont pour eux trop
bref si ce même si ce qu'on vous prend
de me prendre je suis sonné en g8
ça me prend 1,6 en rythme faire [ __ ]
en f2 rhin terme et puis en bref deux
intermédiaires mais voilà ce que je
voulais faire broyer f1 n'a pas changé
l'audi numéro 1
bref un vrai j'aurais joué comme ça oui
c'est avec les gens mais peut-être ça va
tenir que dans le genre leur tour à 6
c'est sûrement peut-être un père peut
être un truc
ok tu vas faire preuve de roue en f1
ces trois matches ça madame f 6 tours
axis voilà un truc comme ça
dames g63 je suis d'arracher 3g à 8
ouais voilà bong est ce que nul n'y a
nulle façon je peux pas offert votre
choix et j'ai pas le temps de ramener la
tour ou quoi ré et je sais pas si tu as
d'autres tempêtes même dingue comme
l'impression de quoi voilà après le ce
que roy h7 c'est jouable
je ferai pas en fait un bond plus en
plus peur de g5 dans les cours
tassin j'aurais pris en f2 perso déjà
ouais ouais ça peut être trop même et
moi même deux pubs ferment je peux aussi
juste après armes et on se dira oui il
est moins bien caché c'est vrai mais vu
qu'on a pas d'échec on était sûr après
un peu comme ça j'aurais dû tour 1 et
tours trois tours à 3 910 le tempo pour
le truc après du coup à des recettes
propres si on prend un f2 en f1
peut-être qu'on a dû d'un meutre ans
pour défendre h 6 h en souffrent drive
the way mon propre chair à fond il faut
reprendre en faisant avec le roi
marine c'est pas simple car on apprend
c'est sûr je pense mais les bons termes
on entre on a regardé même à oui faut
bien à oui oui bravo monsieur c'est joli
il faut bien le très joli mais c'est ok
obligé mais c'est un peu la crise
la petite entreprise as tu peux te faire
autant prendre une belle croix je suis
damage 6,3 g 8 x 2 le retour au tournoi
jeu seulement mayroy h7 du coup et eu
tromperie fera bien voilà c'était sympa
mais on n'a pas vu ni coups dévastateurs
ouais c'est joli un nom jolie
franchement bon alors non franchement
c'était beau là la partie de oui oui
franchement il a fait plaise brouiller
la tue le g2 devrait afficher quatre
villas et eric déjà mais voilà il faut
bien mais faut bien c'est beau
franchement cet éclat ce nom quand il
est beaucoup comme sa femme ça fait
plaisir à voir
or c'est cool sagan a gagné à colmar et
un final il vient avec ses 120 kg et
était accompagné de sept coéquipiers
d'ailleurs bien les autres qu'ils aient
du talent un peu nos équipes n'ont plus
de déficit en fait c'est génial jégo qui
a fait 2 et 3 à colmar je sais pas
voyons nous avons chargé un chat ouais
ouais ce que j'ai toujours eu cet été
j'en ai fait injuste langue corse et le
prochain ça sera en prenant fin août
début septembre
saout france le 31 à trieste en italie
votons beau tournoi
jolie ville sympa
donc ça échange grave assez échangiste
comme pertinents ouais mais bon
peut-être qu'il va tenter la pression
insurgés 7 avec le chou et la tour un
peu comment la partie de carl scène
contre guiry ouais les contres je bavais
où on rapporte que je veux qu'on te
rapporte ouest et ouais exact pris ce
risque et 17 hockey qui avait un câble
j'imagine voilà c'est l'audace et ses
systèmes
les trois sur le candidat fins anti
envie dame un peu miretti mirettes 1
j'aime pas trop ces ouvertures là au
quesnoy rinck les blancs et devrait un
peuple autre nom
bah ouais bah tu as assez solide que ce
grand midam donc tu essaie de trouver un
moyen de garder de la vie dans la
position moins théorique un peu pas
avant c'est même plus en plus évidemment
maintenant c'est devenu très théorique
oui malheureusement
mais quelle image cavaliers ou quatre
qui est marrant ouais attaque les deux
pions fréchuret les bons chevaux trouver
quelque chose pour parer aux quais tour
d un très bien elles sont les cinquièmes
bien c'est bien joué que tu peux doubler
où elle est amère h5 quelque part qui
jouent des 4 j'ai pensé qu'ils
pourraient jouer à 4 4 je sais pas
des tours h5 quand même mais tout rejet
de
intéressante position ouais j'aime bien
les balles en plomb peut être pas mal
pour les blancs en fait ouais il
s'abstint le chou qui est censé être un
peu nous venons gérard position c'est
donc là t'as pas de socle aux biens le
planté au centre
quand je lis pour tous rêvent de tours
prend b2 est il assez concret que ce oui
mais rien n'y fait dans des f1 kg 5
quand j'ai trois ponts
je sais pas de tordre fr toile et n'ont
rien il ya problème j'en vois pas
pour moi ça va mais bon après bâton j'ai
faim les gens kg 5 jade du coup notre
bien aimée roi des trois favoris si
penser à ça mais à quai mais tourage 5
elle sait bien jouer la tourache 5 puis
on prend tout reproche de ne pas je sais
pas je le mieux le retour donc j'étais
ça l'est aussi d'une bêtise en vue
d'oeil je ramenais l'autre un ghetto
rachat responds to rage 3 est
complètement guéri jestin qui nous
guette est nul oui attendait tour des
fins yogini stopper sources avaient tord
df tu te rends passif de partout c'est
un koala perdant ouais f4 wepa des g5
qui vont arriver
j'aime pas du tout alors là mais bon qui
veut chasser le khalife du roi des trois
points 1,05 à f2 et f3 wave euro f3 g5
fife iii mais bien ce que c'était si
bien je n'en sais rien ouais je t'ai
quand vous voulez mais son envol
cavaliers effet y avait problème sur
attia lors en face et s'est tourné cinq
films et des masques lui mais bon après
c'est dur quand tu commandes ce que tu
vois pas tous un nom mais ça on est
moins à la fugueuse mais non ça chauffe
pas mal points noirs en fait finalement
parce que selon m on sait déjà qu'elle
fait retour c'est peut-être là je
voudrais qu'il est doublé les tours ils
mettent un peu embêté sa masse tour ces
deux sa menace laisse tranquille deux
sirops à troquer des 2 1 chaque côté un
épatant faire x 3 ce qui entoure ces 2 3
des trois cavaliers deux arrêts non
c'est chiant tu pensais que j'avais le
temps mais en fait j'ai pas le temps
attends tu me dire tu peux faire pour
être maintenant ben oui et non ça me
fait peur en fait un soin trois tours
ces deux on voit des trois peut-être 3 2
vous prendrez fluide kf2 alors fou des
canes d'accord ok dans ces deux affaires
droit des trois c'est le projet
clairement parce que c'est notre projet
ben c'est un projet printemps quoi ils
pensent printemps très printanier mais
[Musique]
ouais c'est pas assez compliqué comme
christian favre c'est compliqué et il va
en outre une hyper concret on se serait
fait on se serait fait massacrer dans
une petite fille d'anne peuple donc
bientôt ces sept qui faisait trois ans
il envoie quoi ce n'est pas assez
tactique encore continuer bon ben vous
reste trois matches et se faire [ __ ]
en c3 trop d 2 oui oui mais bon laissons
des pièces sont prises quand même pas me
la redonne beaucoup plus l'esprit de la
partie bon en termes de voix reprend 5 à
non mais je pense pas forcément ce sujet
je jouais coup d'oeil comme ça que tu
reprends ses 5 31 est la finale et ce
cas les gagnantes pour les blancs ou pas
pas sûr du tout mais on est à peu près
faire un pas peut-être tour 17 étoiles
françois fillon prend entre 5 et j'ai
faim que je conviens ouais bon bah alors
on fait autour des 5 first prises et 4
et 0 4 pour ces huit tours 17
je pense j'ai tout rêve cinq finales
depuis resté alité camion tout pas parce
qu'en fait travailler plus avec cinq
essais 5 qui bloquait bien quoi faire
notre tour par trois des trois c4
ouais du queens et en d6 une tête des
gagnants quand même mais peut-être un
petit exemple qui traîne un truc je sais
pas d'uranium bon talent fou d'actifs
c'est sur la 4e journée soit 6e c'est
toujours un petit truc auquel je pense
que cet objet de faire si on prend qui
on prend et j'ai cinq ans
ouais parce que
qu'est ce que tu as tout rêve celle ci
ouais c'est un peu paradoxal en fait je
suis tout reprendre à apprendre sur cinq
croit aussi ça les pions pas s'éloigner
mais non je pense que ça va pas gagner
ça à perdre même temps que c'est pas sûr
non julien gil pidoux mégevand sur un
zouk sans engagements donnés par les
neuf sélections avec les passants g5
j'ai pas trop capter pourquoi pas j'ai
seulement peur peur de l'autre finale
mais il a dû quelques tours des cinq
tours à f/5 un we are marked tour des 5
tours 7
et attendre c4 et tout reprend roi
prendre qu'à 3 au 6 mai vous attendez
quoi pour décembre
guy forget ici tu leur écoute
intéressant bonne chance deux nuls mais
préfère touré cet échec est les sacs à
main mais tour à tour et c'est peut-être
sur wade 3d ça mais bon tu peux revenir
27 28 ans et 4 devrait prendre quatre
français 5 touareg 2 à 4 ans cadrage de
déchets croate 6 points 7 pouces et on
est plus ou moins exactes ou et de
mouscron
ouais ok il va prendre à cette prendre
la tête s'ils gagnent un tempo en
prenant h7
ok tu prends le 7 points à 2 dont il
prend à cette proche d'eux qui enfonce
mais il va foncer aussi je pense des
versions améliorées pour les blancs
lorsqu'on regarde il ya trente secondes
il ya un temps de plus non il regardait
de 4 environ
je pense c'est gagnant voir son rôle
pour ce camp reste si tu fais roi ici et
roy price 45.94 fait tu as quand même
deux temps de crise avec les biens
perdus tempo normalement dans ses
positions c'est vraiment une course aux
points 16 rebonds tu as tu pourrais
rajouter un pion noire en est cette
tempête
il pas un cancer mais là c'est mort je
pense qu'elles vont d'après ce que je
pense comprendre ces finales je dirais
que c'est normal en fait ce qu'il veut
faire c'est à vrai dire c'est essayer de
hockey genre la tour prend à 3 tours
prend à cette ça va pour venir face à la
tchèque s'est offert trois camions ok je
sais très bien sans lui quand tu fais
dame tu défends un chat ce qui est
important évidemment mais il a de
l'avant cela nous immiscé sur sa guise
comme peter way papauté pas peter sagan
les dames twh 8 me et le bic et celle et
options d'avancé les deux temps d'avant
de tous alors qu'ils font gagner mais
non des 4 et 5 baies 5 g 4 des 6 g 3d
cette retraite d'alain bouffin on va
arriver dans la plongée deux filles
lundi des fêtes autant prêt moi vous un
bon ben ça c'est série n 2 elle était
belle cette finale ouais bah bravo au
bureau n était pas facile hein bon
nouvèl gunten nouvelle variante il n'a
pas offert ou g5 et machin est vraiment
bien joué la bande forest
pays fait la bande de magnus pas celle
de contre maxime et anti japon même
manière après quoi contre gries choco
sinon ouais donc et je dis plus jaloux
qui est trop le lait 100g a pendant un
moment après le sentir un briquet agnant
f3 et fin juin et parle avec flamme
n'est pas longtemps et les oui enfin il
l'est pas donc les positions étaient
vraiment désespérée en fait la papa
désespérée mais dit oui enfin tu as
quand même besoin chiite haq a besoin de
borg mcenroe enfin je fais tu n'as pas
que born fois qu'ils gagnent ou enfin
ces trois mondes et non non on vise plus
que bien se réveille toi mais je passe
comme ça et rogers état et que rogers
tout le temps bon à ce que ça veux c'est
en 2003 2004 mais évidemment maïs bien
arriver quoi des minerais en 2004 s'est
pas oui c'est pas une balle trop longue
mais oui parce que même garé en fait il
lui car preuves dans les pas 30 ans et
après la dominer mais tu as de la
nouvelle génération qui arrivait avec
s'était endetté cramique et avait des
mecs pas mal je sois les barrières fou
quoi karpov bon été décrit dans médi pas
encore finie natale et quelle famille
massacrée par massacrer packard peuvent
par exemple c'est peut-être pas le nom
mais non mais en fait ça s'est fait tu
prends le bus est ouest alors que là
c'est vraiment un massacre mais il y en
a aucun qui est proche
en fait non le plus proche sera bientôt
faut que quelqu'un se réveille quoi ça
se révèle aussi ce n'est pas les deux
bailly pour en live bien uon 2 mondial
oui les détacher or ça c'est clair
mais bon après dans le match devrait
commencé le seul qui a réussi à le tenir
sur douze parties en partie longue
bakary kino si oui des rongeurs sont que
ça m'amuse qui s'est tenue tout seul
contre eux car iachini c'était tout seul
contre fabiano il ya un vrai match moyen
contre car yakine karekin
ok il tient sur des forteresses sur des
trucs incroyables non louise état et
puis il s'est énervé et puis il perd une
partie tout seul en force en comminges
où brillent quand même y remonter ouais
mais ça fait perdre le match à cause de
ça parce que car yakine il presse à
prague on thilleman à zéro en fait des
positions dit mieux celle qui perd en
fait il a un père pète qui vois pas
paris fait beaucoup de 10 7e tout le
match en main et ok null null bon et
rapide
ouais c'est vrai en plus que la partie
ou hyper il avait un père pète pas trop
dur en plus à voir non pas pas facile
mais ok tu m'insultes champion du monde
tu vas voir je gagne dit que la
confiance en ben moi j'ai pas trop
confiance en vous le dis franchement je
suis pas super confiant là pour pour les
grands prix bas les grand prix des fêtes
ça traumatise polluer les mains ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que les points de bonus
c'est important mais alors là par contre
gagnant des matches longs c'est pas
parce que vous pourrez me regarde c'est
que tu dis si tu fais demi tu fais que
trois points en fait ouais en fait tu
passes un tour te marque un point
c'est très peu à ça se passe
un point après tu passes à trois points
suivants demi 5 point final et 7 points
victoire du tournoi est en fait les
points de bonus du coup c'est hyper
important
je regarde là qu'il ya déjà cette année
n'est pas aussi il a fait des victoires
il est éliminé en rognant sur deux
parties et un autre j'ai fugué
mais du coup on n'a qu'à qui a fait
qu'ils avaient fait que des nuls rapides
ont fait la queue trois points qu'elle a
fait des mines finale mais au final
enfin tu as et ben non mais par contre
j'aime bien le système que de favoriser
la victoire en lançant moi je vous sais
très bien ça mais à la fin ce qu'elle me
tende roland tu vas jouer toit du monde
deux partis classiques vache mais l'on
oublie parce que la ldh prime ans et
plus
depuis très longtemps fait magnus et l'a
gagné aucun match encore non enfin la
mise à part contre un pas de plus
attendre vois tu es champion du monde
mais tu n'as jamais gagné pas tu ne
gagne plus depuis quatre ans ouais c'est
ça mais bon là bons jusqu'alors mais en
tournant
ça ne pas la même impression après les
matches c'est particulier non mais je ne
sais pas disons
ok les tournois il est gagné plus donc
le plus bas j'exagère un poil coualy
anguilles quelques-uns en est ce juste
assez quand même très partagés mais ce
nom la cellule d'affilée c'est une belle
domination après 1 mais bon juste on
aimerait bien avoir un numéro de émerger
histoire d'avoir un peu de tension parce
que sinon ces menaces ont vraiment un
numéro deux mais pas si menaçants et
pourtant ils jouent bien ah bah oui mais
là c'est 28-20 il les tient c'est chaud
ouais non mais c'est dingue mais manu
c'est vraiment sur le planet un vrai que
gomis et vlad un trike doubow saman
vraiment métamorphosé
ouais ayé bonduois fin sympa en plus
cette dame f4 et si je pensais mais bien
que fixe ok on sait cette bahia préfère
c4 tu le sais bien
une bonne idée et tu deviens le van gogh
de la position dégage toujours plus deux
oreilles carrément de bacchus tard van
gogh améliorer quoi c'est très bien joué
c'est joli dans les quatre cinquième
membre ouais il va essayer d'aller à
2009 un magnus un travail immense il
peut le faire
franchement il peut après ce qui peut se
payer ce qui peut faire une écroule à un
moment donné je sais pas après guy
l'ampleur d'une des pires qu'on verra
mais ce qui fait même plus en fait ça
avant souvent hyper dans les premiers
rangs du temps on se chauffe et vous
avez six nuls sa machine
il ya déjà mis le moteur sur sur son
vélo dès les premiers hectomètres et
monstrueux ouais ça ça manque un peu de
suspense mais bon du coup c'est tout
l'intérêt des grands prix et des
candidats mais il n'est pas là oui ça
joue plus intéressants du coup alors il
valait quelqu'un ok j'ai vu le gala qui
a écrit le livre sur sa vie si je vous
en ai je tourne yarn ouais ouais qui en
fait était trop dominants aura me laisse
vraiment une taupe ajustons les
décombres des morts ne se bat pas
deuxième
coire et en plus c'est des champions il
va falloir participer c'était quand même
le titre de champion du monde en fait
qui se jouait mais sans toit en fait
[Musique]
c'est très bien mais tu dis j'ai le
droit de dire non ou pas même avec
handicap a pris le refuser et qui est ce
que dans votre j'avoue qu'il ya un coup
de fouet à kraft food est vite fait pour
prendre le foot français s'ils sont
inclus c'est un beau coup ça et c'est
pas juste on recycle un peu ouvert et si
ces fermes avoir des problèmes là-bas
free ride c'est un coup de foudre est ce
parce que je sais pas si c'est aussi
force esthétique mais il va gagner un
vivat méthode avoir fait le tour en un
set pour l'instant et nord sous les
bombes et autres 4,5 greenwald j'occupe
c'est génial il enferme son cavalier
c'est extraordinaire ce que tu veux
faire battre des six jours pour
constituer la paix elle est rousse et
watch non je peux
c'est marrant quand je les change pas
les dames dégage ne fait pas très utile
rêve un truc c'est que jafar france et
six au prochain et puis calais habitat
dieu que c'est beau et c'est ce qu'il a
fait nous dit on peut prendre entre six
mois et cherchait en b 6 - versez simple
ouais ok pour ces huit du coup le retour
il est temps pensé si cet emprunt ce
système il va lier le cavalier à huit
c'est joli comme partir du site de stx
et belle domination demain c'est assez
pédagogique le pont ouais c'est parti
sympa ça la meilleure des maîtres partie
dans les dents les speechs s oui mais
c'est plus la victoire peut soit être
très content de ma chemise merci alors
voilà enfin la ramener de la bonne
humeur
je sais pas comment tu gagnes ce que tu
fais genre ou de f4 je le maintiendrai
mec est un mec tu prends des ces six
équipes rc5 et aux cinq sens bien mais
je sais que ça gagne ces trucs là mais
je sais que je vais réussir à gagner
normalement mécaniquement mais peut-être
tu prends ces six français cinq rifle ou
huit tours machin voilà toi cette tour f
5 me ont déjà tué plus j'ai fait j'ai
quatre peut-être
voici ce qu'ils ont fait de nous faire
et petit à petit con répéteront zoug
je pense qu'il me manque quand même un
f4 bas je pense que le moins ses chronos
avait parlé mais là c'est sûr que c'est
fini et on peut prendre mais hkd
bon ça s'abandonne quasiment non moi bah
pas s'il veut essayer on sait jamais
mais bon oui trop d'espoir après sur la
connexion tout est possible ouais ok là
trente secondes bousquet n'est rien et
puis depuis le début sa collection a pas
été affreuse n'est pas bonne mais pas à
pelé moment où il a pas les banques 15
secondes s'est passée la réunion
il se bat je bois bon h 5 h 15 j'ai
quatre mois je vais faire ça colle c est
voilà food et 5 la nuit ou demain très
bien ça surprend aussi s'en fait
maintenant on va finir 5 et puis non je
sais pas pourquoi je vous fait le genre
défend bien on est pris par une sorte
d'inertie tu joues chaîne hbo parce que
tu joues tu sais pas perdre sa bataille
fut détroit froid wet ones 30 mg faire
pour ces trois tours ces quatre types
stratégie sur quoi enfin zuma qui doit
manoury 15 coups evans les mavericks ont
après turin passait sur un truc fait
tourner 5 mai pour que je donne ma télé
à revin oui je suis toujours là il a
fait un pari à tenter le pape s'était
bien joué ouais mais ça on le voyait
venir fin riche je sais qu'il a une idée
en tête se planter sa sa petite peau de
banane et là il a une idée quoi c'est
déjà ça bon on fait des savanes a émis 6
1 dans le deuxième set s'achève
bungert je sais pas mais oui mais alors
du coup cette partie sa raison dans la
bande clairement c'est exactement la
même en fait c'est la partie qui avait
gagné avant de forest à ses propres
bandes ailleurs ouais bah si la phase
finale mais il ya un moment donné ça
allait pour wii et meilleures sinon la
finale en soi était elle était jolie oui
oui m
donc on partira intéressant d'après ce
pas forcément les plus passionnantes
m'ont plu fab
même si c'est des belles finales aux
techniques mois quant à elle quand un
une deux à temps je suis fier comme tu
le sais j'ai toujours un oeil pour voir
si j'ai pas ci fais pas une erreur je
vous rejoins sur les téléphones facile
sur leur dit c'est bon on est bon donc
petite position petite finale
bref cette tour g8 probablement en tout
cas bref c'est sûr on va remettre la
tour sur la colonne d
on ici on a une pièce cloud et qu'on
n'est pas de ces nuls basse tu veux pas
jouer ses pattes en fait ouais c'est nul
que tu es une pièce deux pièces trois
pièces 10 pièces pour le battre et c'est
à zéro coût des galas jour
indépendamment du nombre de pièces
quotas il y avait un truc le pack le
plus rapide du monde tu fais en quinze
coups jusqu'au bout c'est sous le roi et
par 38 m6 bref c'est 3g 6h 6-3 ça te
trompes les laisses tu bloques tous bien
d'ailleurs ces impacts qu'ils ont
utilisés dans un épisode de mister
nobody
non mr au bâton à kehl à quelles fins
bah en fait
[Musique]
ok bon c'est à ce moment là c'est lent
on est quoi ce sont trop 4 on sait après
la saison une que mister robot de fait
c'est lui ok je sais pas il joue aux
échecs ont pu lui-même en fait et il
veut gens se débarrasser de l'autre et
valider ce titre que oui le vainqueur
cette partie sera celui qui pilotera le
corps on va dire ouais en fait il faut
que des nuls est la seule partie que tu
vois ces stars où ils font pas
donc il a mis la tourache trois signes
assez malin parce qu'il attaque plus
rage 17 exactement en quelque sorte
h6 skis à faire f 5 tu penses pas idiot
pour mieux la structurer ces
organisations pas de people prépare un
peu mais peut-être ses joueurs déjà
fouet f6 après essayer de penser que
jeff 5e f tout le papier g3 un des
théâtres aux fenêtres 4 le 30 le 5 fu va
me faire huer fin d'un bail la carrière
le 4 1 mais je faisais déjà exsangues et
que les blancs un jeu de mots derrière
soi je pensais que celle idées noires f5
oui mais c'était parfait avec les blancs
mais juge me dit oui donc le fcg 3 et f4
ouais c'est logique intermédiaire
pourquoi pas ouais bien ouej 3 c'est la
question
ouais c'est vrai scoop le rêve 3e point
d'être kaliev 2 du coup si on n'a pas
trop envie de perdre d2 ou en parle
mieux mais on perd mais critique laurent
les derniers instants de calme la contre
attaque sur des deux roues des rois fin
à 20 kg 3 tours des 8 où on a poussé 3 -
qui tient
je pars c'est lui qui avait les abdos
aussi impossible
quatre cavaliers
est-ce que qui avait lieu 5 c'est un
coup ici baupin que tu as tout reprend
f2 et cavaliers v4 attention le cheapos
de sortie et ou 3 2 qui a été trois
héros c est qu elle prend b2 pendant
s'est tendue quand même l'appareil de
menaces comment est ce que les blancs
voient leurs six faits tour f1 il va
peut-être y avoir droit aux six pieds
pas fab
c'est tendu
ok mais à tourcoing 2 qui a été 3
écailles prend b2 à mes cavaliers ont
fermé à la fin
ouais il est temps un petit tour bien
que je le mets alors attendons ce pas
sur 3,3 garder à temps a changé de mains
ouais et 3 octobre sous votre royaume ou
alors parfois de qu'éprouvent les deux
on attaque pas direct mais il faut faire
un truc contre tours j'ai deux médailles
soit être protégé après aussi ouais
assez chaud c'est un peu une potion
d'études la formule un cliché et je
pense qu'il a raté en fait la fin je
crois pour éviter truc avec éclat il
s'est dit ok va être enfermé et pas de
chance un problème c'est un vrai
problème
ce que si l'enfer pas de cavalier c'est
mort alors pas encore mais bon mais
souvent là pour faire bref inquiets
prend b2 genre courage 7 3 bougez tour
j'ai un échange d'une tour et tout à
tour des deux pièces qui se bat dans les
finales capturer dire aussi ce nom
et peut-être la plongée de l'échec en
premier league et wav 2 est ok c'est
plus ou moins ce que je disais tu sort
final tu peux un peu lutté wintour en
milieu de jeu c'est très faible une tour
contre ces deux pièces il ya beaucoup de
billets sont la tour un peu pas
s'activer truc ckac et qui arrive en cfa
et taper à deux mois j'aurais bien aimé
gamins qu'ils encouragent cette et
chacun jouant ce matin je pense ça va
être gagnant pour les noirs mme c'était
pas si simple pas tout ça mais c'est
vrai que perdre à 2m dommage on va
prendre 5 est fière du a5 la chanson
valence et ouais c'est pas idéal
après y avions passé h
mais bon le roi quand même bien dans
leboncoin allait dans le bon corner
non c'est pas idéal clairement pour pour
les blancs et si la paire sais que ça
peut commencer à faire match ce sera le
premier break du match
exact il est surtout qui pousse un peu
quoi ouais enfin et surtout qu'on a
l'impression que wailly domine bien avec
les blancs et avec les noirs bas mais
ils perdaient de justesse mais sakho et
clément et domine bien mais en fait
ouais il en a perdu de justesse et la
cie commence à gagner avec les noirs tu
vois ça peut aller vite quoi après donc
ce n'est pas encore fini fini
non non non mais bon ok il vient bien
joué mais je pense son purgatoire b4
même des cas ce qui arrive réellement
réussira plus celle qui fait pas mais
regarde les quatre baies 3 et 1 4 ap un
temps prend 1,4 les deux tomes * il
suffit la marée au blanc mais quand même
des tours 6 ans donc et suis pas sûr
qu'ils la gagnent en fait laurent blanc
quand même très actif
peut-être des 4 way
peut-être des 4es pour se débarrasser du
pion des cas je dirais aux passants
reprend mais pas d'éclats en fait humain
qu'à lyon le 5 et tu vas concert
voudront vers h4 ces dégâts ni options
toit de hockey c'est 3g six cavaliers 5
c'est qu'il sonne direct pourquoi pas
bon va-t-on trouver des fonds de chez
north est assez harmonieux toulouse tout
bien quoi et si je dépends de kylie
kylie fond ces quatre récits de m
laurent f5 peut-être pour empêcher au
roi noir d'avancé justement voiturier h4
aprem en commençant par wild 5
les notes un peu bloqué à clément
injuste que d'être léger handicap mais
qui savait pas suffire mais comme
d'aborder deux essais car je veux pas
trop en quoi ça empêche les mois
passaient plutôt nouveau patron qu'ils
soient tous là immobiliste à thouars
défense du psion c'est un une colonne
pour peut-être s'activent s'était plaint
de raquette je sais pas oui bon
fièrement c'est très bien mais jean
tirole à maïs est très basse très
concret ce qui fait et lui wiland marché
à 3 tours français 4 à 2 ouais émergents
voient plus loin c'est du rhin mais
ouais bah écoute voilà tour à 2 à 3 wet
water à trois rois des quatre cas et
c'est un les siens et kébé trois
français qui font foi
du coup pourquoi cordes et kad merad et
5 ni frais comme elle se bat pas mal je
trouve
ok c'est un tour ces deux fous prend dès
demain
peut-être qu'à lycéens du coup de rein
mais il faut prendre les deux est froide
et de 3,3 inquiet en baie de bois et
défense ont pu en fait c'est peut-être
le plus simple il prend un blog pour
prévenir une attaque des deux c'est un
problème en baie de hawke et bel ouvrage
par efficace 11 56 hockey
et ces trois montées s'avance avant tu
vas le quart joué car il faut 2,5
bon il reste 5 ou pire mais même hors
norme et senna il abandonne look et vous
croyez vrai que dans le match pour
bonjour je suis moins rire et de chiens
qui est sensé qui domine quand même un
dans le contenu aussi mais c'est bien
elle est en transe la satire qu'il
arrête un peu la nouvelle diffusée
massacre ce que faire le fou de carlson
mieux je veux la même chose que carl
c'est vrai oui dit le pass le hollandais
passe à l' orange il toujours un long
range donc il reste combien minutes dans
ce cinq plus un fab
il reste il reste 22 minutes donc il
reste deux caps à leur actif prendre
peut-être pas ce qu'une partie ça peut
durer onze minutes quoi ça dépend ça
fait deux fois 11 ça fera ça fera ça
fera deux parties de près d'eux ça
dépend et paraissant même assez longues
a jusqu'à maintenant
ouais pour l'instant c'est long mais de
temps en temps et donc de coût 5 h 4
n'empêche à cinq points c'est logique
pet et non même cinq cars annonce
formelle de mode ce qui joue pas mais
c'est vrai que ça rende du couac en fait
flouer
c'est le premier changement je te sens
regarder départir la journée hier de feu
deux fait combien est parti jouer et si
on avait encore pas mal de films si la
salle emstal et qui a joué mieux que
c'est aussi ce gros coupage et 6 mai
aujourd'hui une seule preuve mais c'est
rarissime il était sale et salem sa
plastique et blanc non bah ouais il s'en
prend au fuji kaï sans frontières cette
affaire d'état match 5
moi j'adore les blancs ici en baisse
bien face et regarde côté blanc talent
and india pti flou c'est plus que je
suis pas sûr trangé 600 voix c'est ce
que j'étais en train de regarder tu as
il ya très peu de parties pas vendre de
très fort
c'est plus aussi sous b4 les cours n'ont
en fait ce qui est inquiétant c'est que
c'est que la mode de wailly qui jaillit
facilement avec les blancs elle continue
et il advient un break d'avancé si en
fait il retourne une deuxième fois avec
les noirs avaient le poids face à ses
côtés ce qui est des jeux blancs au
service et quant au dessert en quelqu'un
tu perds à 40-30 davantage machin tout
la croche et un jour tout le moins un
rack et j'ai continué forte jeu blanc
sale déclarant que domine quand c'est
comme ça mais bon après l'autre jour le
match pays-bas contre raonic sur une
facile facile effet un moment donné en
fait tu vois tu n'es plus un jeu de
service pas tu vois c'est il est épuisé
ce qu'il a fait j'ai pas vu le match
comme moi j'ai vu en fait mais eux non
mais parce qu'il est dingue se paya
c'est pas du tout aux joueurs de surface
rapide avait déjà il est lent il est
lent gazon cette année ouais balles sont
lourdes mais oui c'est les balles
apparemment may hamm et du coup non mais
raonic fait j'ai déjà eu pas mal de
matches joly parce que j'aime bien et en
fait je remarque que fait c'est comme si
l'adversaire commence à lire son service
un moment donné ou quoi mais pas les
habitudes mais à un moment donné en fait
il pas ainsi sa première balle elle fait
plus aussi mal en fait il peut être un
peu nul quoi bah c'est quand même son
charme principalement de jeu mais le
service arabe ni deux je te fait jouer
des balles en mousse ça va aller mais tu
vois le service d'isner je trouve quand
il est en forme plus dangereux en fait
les options qui contrôlent plus le point
en fait il a moins besoin de faire le
point direct ça il n'y a pas d'âme c'est
vite la cie pour chatons elle c'est vrai
j'ai vu tempo attention pour le savoir
ouais c'est fini en fait son abandon
et donc ça continue nouveau jeu blanc
mais là vraiment blanc des noms mais je
pense que en fait vendre forest il va
falloir qu'ils retournent dans les bois
chercher les ouvertures a joué 4 non
mais là ils sont compliqués qui est le
4e 2 tout ça fera quatre hommes
d'affaires du jamais vu de ma vie
d'avant ces types flâne on se bat soit
c'est ils tous et nous y lancer tilt fab
ça ressemble à du team jeu mais bon on
va voir maintenant right it girl
maintenant à jouer contre 1,1 m fidji
v30 oui me jolin grob l'a-40 et après il
m'a fait à 6b 6 et 6 2 6 2 6 7 6 et 6 1
6 0
bah oui mais ça c'est tranche 3 peut-il
jouer pour en être autrement d'étranges
ouais j'ai mon bouquin il te dis que
c'est pas très intéressant on fera une
vidéo peut-être d'ailleurs dessus
l'argent sera gérée comme vidéo mais
peut-être pourrait faire une vidéo sur
le pat le plus rapide du monde
par espace trouve c'est marrant comme
truc en revanche il est une passe et a
senti un truc scientifique 3,5 la ce a
pas d'intérêt direct à cette pédagogie
non mais j'aime bien à 4 h 20 c'est le
match qui fait payer tout bois ça reste
encore un peu intuitive non maintenant
il va lui coller dessus on va te mettre
le foin à 3 on va vous justifiez tous
nos coups tourage 400 g 4 c'est à dire
tous les côtés le fantastique mettant h4
à mme cassez une française en fait même
du coup tu vas trésor au nom d'un jeu
3-0 en fout d'eux ne pêchait pas
exactement l'intérêt de foden son
attitude autant de chose en f1 quand il
veut mais que penser une position qui
peut être devoir vraiment une position
de français ce genre coup par coup point
par point
non mais juste et blanc quand même des
temps de retard ce qu'ils aient fait des
trois des quatre étaient touchés
car ils ont fait c6 c5 ces quatre
français devance rennes mentale à cause
de ce très cher payé 3 qui est un cadre
aussi des 4 des 5 et 6-3 4-6 5-4 et du
tu prends pas toutes les souffrances et
devant lille hockey c'est peut-être
possible drame avec moins de sion ok
c'est intéressant parce qu'en face il
fait d'amener de protéger une purée 20
points 4 mrd de donc des affaires droit
des 2 1 et c'est logique voire des deux
mais je veux juste dire que théorie j'ai
pas dis pas grave tu voulais faire un
nom de façon de base bois au dessus de
100 en juin ou dans les fins fonds sait
pas ce qu'il fait mais juste ce qu'il
faut de gp mais je comprends pas du tout
fait l'intéressé était un joueur de
française non mais à moins qu'il ait
joué là bas elle madame x à tout rachat
ils veulent la paix semble bien et là tu
as besoin de sentir floués et si non en
fait je pensais qu'ils essaient de faire
tout rage 4 et ils ont soit au f4 pour
bloquer les deux j'ai vraiment pas
compris baïla près mais j'ai parents des
deux intrus qui va pas où il a prévu pas
pensé je sais pas peut-être séparément
joueurs de française eu un souci
n'ont pas manqué le 6e à l'église n'a
pas du tout aimé garder ce vous en
faites pas trop mais bon tu pourra
revenir un jour en a trois c'est pas
trop de questions attendent évidemment
tu paieras tant de temps trois temps tu
as un peu moins trois échecs peut être
que d'autres fait recaler h4 ce que m6 a
souvent trop vite fait chaud qui h4
essaye de faire piéger six f4 bloquer
tout le mois je sais pas peut-être tu
vas pas l'air d'être convaincu dans le
cube et laroque
je comprends mieux la femme bas et rock
non mais je pense qu'ils jouent jamais
ses positions en fait b il fut le cas
pourtant en france mais il peut être
qu'il veut une autre arme sur la
française belge et cahiers ces trois
d'habitude il a battu une belle partie
qu'on ai dit je te 12 ya deux ans bon on
ne devrait pas à fond mais mais c'était
sur la banque et ses trois cannes et 6 e
5 et 17 tous à adam b6 vite
c'est assez étonnant en fait il fait
vraiment le plan un peu à l'envers de ce
qu'ont fait normalement non ouais il a
fallu du temps il a traîné deux manches
ce que fout 18 est ce que fait je prends
à 30 sont floues fins précises mais non
ils vont le faire j'ai si souvent qu'on
savoure et un rouleau de côté mais m6 et
surtout je pense qu'ils veulent faire
une marque et 6e savoie dafoe et huit
gagnants 5 et d'actifs tous plus que
j'ai 6 ans la fille s'est apparemment
plus plus dans le dans le tempo
mon nom est celui du truc est de nature
à déboucher en souabe et 6 soit qui sait
si je sais pas
c'est bizarre partira ou x 8 tu as fait
réveiller du conseil tout en 36
il y aura rien il y aura rien non non
mais juste revenu de personnes et tuent
pas garder ton roi ici j mais en fait
j'ai pas honte et regrets devant de fer
3.7 je sais pas quoi enfin la retrouves
par un temps était juste sur de plus à
jamais avoir rien de temps concept de
télé c'est pas faux mais je ne veux
juste faire france et quatre noms qui
ont croqué france et 4 et ouais mais tu
as complètement désabusé par la partie
non les hommes je pensais qu'il a peur
ses chances et en fait ils lycéens
massacrés l'ancien mais le problème
c'est si cette partie est un massacre le
match devient un massacre
le sata 6 2 peut-être tenter toujours à
mais le roi mais ça tu m'aimes pas ce
que je fais non non rires là s'effacer
yasi et aurait des conséquences non mais
c'est vrai que tu as raison quand on
fixe à un problème si perdre cette
partie puisque en perdant cette partie
en fait s'il perd tout ok le match n'est
pas complètement plié mais ça fait mal
vu le scénario du match et vu tout ce
qu'on a dit avant de break ça parait dur
mais exactement
c'est marrant j'ai un peu snob
nouveautés mises en jeu dix mecs qui
domine mais en fait à part du monde a
fait le premier break en fait c'est ça
prend l'eau de partout mais des moines
dans tous les sens ap sept tours à huit
car ils croient bay 6-5 tab on a moins
de planter une peau de banane trop
spoiler
non mais tu vois souvent les matches
comme ça genre rafa contre quelqu'un 4-4
dans le premier y premier set et enfin
vous coffin choco d'air france à suivre
il se fait braquer une fois voyez que 4
4 c'est pas très grave indécis c'est
grave votre culture a est à 4
bon là plus super 6 4 6 0 et 6 arrêts
mais c'est dur un mental mais bon le
sens nous aussi quand tu joues genre de
match contre quelqu'un quand tu sors tu
sens je vais pas trop de temps des trucs
comme ça mais des trucs comme ça qu'on
des mecs plus fort en fait tu peux te
faire enchaîner un moment donné tu peux
juste en perdre 10 d'affilée après tu
tiens tiens tiens un moment je n'en peux
plus ouais c'est fini en fait d'un plot
souhaité l'ouverture ça se passe mal
tout se passe mal et temps peu plus en
fait tu es bon en fait s'il faut dire
que je n'y vais plus haut le niveau de
résistance et plus haute la pièce un
acte s ok c'est bien c'est une belle
tours à huit ce serait une option aussi
on se prépare c'est à dire de rendu qui
habitent ou quoi new dawn g5 très bien
mais c'est dur c'est d'ailleurs sa part
a fait ce genre de match c'est horrible
c'est tout d'un coup tu temple aux corps
est bien celui tweb et le ferrand ans et
7 ans 8
bref un sur kevin vitesse rouler vite et
tour des six oui ça mais alors je sais
même pas si grave memorex donne
toutefois trop exotiques et ça c'est
bien qu ils connaissent la bonne et
circulent auxquels a peut-être fait je
pense que tu joue vite et bien avec les
blancs cette fille qui est née mais t'as
pas tout reprendre
tu te rends à cette double essadki et
les suces ouais mais en fait bizarre
qu'il prénomme juste un bon existants b8
mais oui c'est embrouillé le jeu au
moins je sais pas toujours pas cette
opération et laissé son v8 étape c'est
un beau tour du bmi tam tam et damien et
je reviens vers à 3,5
je suis complètement gagnant je pense
bien sûr j'ai encore du dab et saddam
ces six jours mais je sais pas mais en
retrait de 47 ont du peps à telus g4
tape si ça vient de tous les côtés et il
a failli oublier leurs forces que les
4es avec celui qui est éliminé en soi
mais l'ordinateur donne plus 3 c'est
dame c'est un oui mais logique je
l'aimais
l'observatoire est fantastique ok
souffert de huit mois se tenir à cga
l'évêque dans le chat qui écrit oui
j'aurais mieux jouer la partie que lui
voilà il fait le chat de partout pas
mais bon attendons qu'un client un homme
à trois dames ce site de lassac d'un v6
qu'elle est à 6 ans et 6 québec à trois
c'est celle d'un rival à finir femmes
pour faire dire ça se voit quoi
peut-être été trop facturés case noire
et tout moment tu mets et l'ordi il va
finir face il veut voir les trucs et
c'est ce que l'a dit je vois un trou j'y
rentre mais bon on peut en trouver cas
ce n est pas tout rage c'est mitterrand
en 8es genre je me bats pas rêver c'est
un truc comme ça mais ça donne pas très
envie pour les rares évidemment même si
tu le fais que reprendre des 8es qu'il
ya dan beck à présent déjà pas si
horrible c'est un peu mieux les culs
blancs mais qui est plus 3 tu vois ces
grosses évaluations font me semble
sévère c'est pas tout simple l'énigme
rien +2 après caraïbes et 4 dames c'est
celle d'un projet 5 et dames bk 3,8
ouais c'est déjà plus + 0 7
mais elle va prendre mais vite en fait
seulement il vasiljevs renouveau est fou
mais peut-être suffisante pour tracer
avec les normes
étonnant quand même 7 partie 1 c'est
c'est la mauvaise partie du match entre
guillemets ouais mais ton d'alger 5
était très bien en fait pour lire du
juste échange les dames et je prends
jamais ce genre de trucs mascelli d
avoir fait que tu as bien ni d'en
traduire ce qu'on a vu ici tu te trompes
une pomme banane je lis pas sur les
climats mais il a pris 1 mesdames c'est
ça qui va tenir
guedah massifs après les habitent
peut-être si madame monsieur faire dame
daaras et adam mb saddam hussein
ouais ne me dise m'ont vraiment fait
juste en effet un signe chez pas si
simple pour les bonnes causes
canam a lancé cinq mille veut faire
trouver cette je pense ceci me tue
encore tirant à 7
y'a tu peux garder d'amanvi très loin
que les messieurs il faudra montrer un
plan qu'eiffarie enfin la pendule là
parce que oui il nous reste connexion
quand même un peu tout ça c'est qu'on
pointe de cordage prudence est plus rock
et 95 kg et là je pense qu'il a bien
joué mais non il faut faire dame cet ami
du monde messieurs + connexion fait il
va trouver je leur 9.88 c'est bien vu
une chance qu'il est juste en ps parce
qu'elle n'a pas une bonne connexion
ces six dames 7 il faut des fouilles 8
j'aime bien différent j'ai unités
soutient tout ils n'arrivent pas à
remonter au temps ouais sans que le prix
mover nacion il faut éviter qu'elles et
ils remontent
pam il va tomber je le sens non mais
c'est horrible ce qu'on veut c'est pas
j'ai pas envie qu'ils tombent
j'ai pas envie d'y perdre comme ça
et tu sens qu'il va tomber dans je sais
pas vous prie passez à la saône rhône
heures il faisait la paire pas ton temps
bizarre comme décision tu connaîtrais
med a fortement par le truc c'est que je
suis faut que tu saches de plus vite
quoi ce que là il ya annuler qu'aide à
main et machin annuler ces voleurs pour
lui parti un peu folle qu'elle va très
longtemps qu'on n'aura plus aux convois
une peut-être
ah ouais il reste 5 minutes 04 donc oui
il sera la dernière et il veut refaire
les cépages et 6 justement les 4 ou 6
mhz et ça c'est la partie de magnus
contre mais je pense que mes quatre ou
cinq noms leur parti oui mais 4,5 à
renverrait en bluff demi vrai quand il
c'est vrai que ça reste comme un bon
résultat pour boeing malgré tout un
match assez intéressant normes on voit
des parties pas mal bon alors c'est
devant l'apathie folle mais finalement
bon eu du suspense c'est vrai qu'il y
moi le truc pas une belle finale il ya
quelques beaux trucs non sa vie le flou
est un pays aux annonceurs et là c'est
là bas c'est pas mal bijoux en pâte
c'est vraiment juste avec un tout le
moins pour les compensations dans quel
centre et tu es jeux sur les cases sa c5
peut-être quoi le foot mais cette
sixième à trine pls augustin
alors bougez bougez ces cinq peut-être
ou quoi j'ai des problèmes
ces cinq là à tête pions prend fou prend
que les premiers singles ça a été
horrible
si c'est ça qu'on peut faire mais
heureux mhadjou ça toute ma vie avec les
noirs suez c5 a égalisé pas être a pris
l'avantagé avec le pion plus un c'est
fini en fait
je suis pas trop près réfléchir on suit
carioca direct et c5 déjà et ce qu'ils
regardent plus g5
j'ai pas ça c'est ce à quoi je ferai pas
bonjour ça marche mais bougez 5 sûrement
il a essayé mais dame b 6 mai puis ça a
juste l'air bien pour les joueurs que
non et c'est bien joué ça c'est quoi ces
quatre que tu fais d'un rêve
ok je me fous calculs et puis on prend
un super match 3 qui est pro 5 par
contre c'est hautement précis ça marche
pas c'est de la merde d'un match 3 comme
ça pas du tout pour les blancs lors des
10 ou non juste battu le maître mais
jamais le redis quasi voit tout mais moi
je dirais je vois enfin je sais pas je
vous sais position là depuis toujours ok
non l'ordi te dis pas clair après f4
c'est un pote la 7e 30 pts - en fait je
te dis f4 l insee f4000c 4 x 5 g 6 il
est rendu là il change d'avis et il te
fais cinq mois ok je te dis c'est quand
même mieux pour les noirs ya moins un
mais mais c'est chaud ok mais je crois
de projets communs fouetter les blancs
sont nuls quatre tours
bon allez je tente quelque 6 mais
jusqu'où pouvait pas jouer récepteur
mairie cgr et jeudi 20 points f5
cavalière paris vii
il s'en fout quoi et tu peux à reprendre
avec l'europe ce qu'adam 3,5 et tu te
fais maths et web ont des trucs
injouable et kiev étaient proches aussi
ce qu'est ce que peut-être juste de me
17 alors dit zidane b6 loud i'm décès
d'hommes mais c'est beau la vente de
leur disant ouais je t'envoie trois
pions dans la gueule je t'en donne un
quatrième se défonce qua non mesdames 17
et qu'on est juste
baisse de régime du joueur chinois de
faire un petit break
morpho faut quand même la finir mais
mais mais le chinois il craque un peu
dans notre attention tant son jeu en
pliant s'accélérer plus il va être en
danger que les connexions ouais bien sûr
mais là bien déconner quand même nom
entre la partie précédente et celle là
il a déconné c'est vernant je sais pas
où il a patiné
puisque vous êtes eric un fou de 6ème et
sa fille n'a pas fait de coup de shu
était noir et déroulés les faits les
coups normaux et clément il a fouillé
tous les pions pour un alizé dans
l'esprit à fond quoi me nourrir
non mais en fait il a menacé en voiture
leurs dires ils renvoyaient deux a
encore faim fallait continuer en fait
fallu envoyer les pions de partout voilà
ces morts ne va pas au curé que deux
points d'écart s'il vend de forest gagne
parce que là le temps fans de toute
façon c'est la dernière de cinq plus un
petit peu après une petite pause de cinq
minutes après ouais cool et les
plaignants il veut faire flasher 5 pour
tenter le piège ah oui moi bien tant pis
après j'ai ici suis peut-être un peu la
gueule mais nathan pin moment il raconté
bon balle de set pour autres jeunes dans
ce cas les deux hommes à ira donc du
coup fable comment on fait f4 tête sais
pas qu'est ce qu'on tente
je sais pas mais fait que ça madame
mirage iii d'une finale qu'ils n'ont
plus ces fissures sur d'options et tupac
ouais mais bon se développent un jeu
normal ça peut être fausse est le tour
quelque part dix huit chevaux est bien
naturel
deux des six qui menacent bon c'est pas
simple simple encore femme s'est pas
fait encore un quand même wesh
non mais femme oui tu peux car est
peut-être embrouillé dans tu fais tes
points 7 kalou est ok autour d un bon
boucher souche ou le défendre battus
menace déjà non mais tout un cto rude ce
qu'ils disent et des six mais c'est
surtout d'éviter la mefou des 8 g fois à
trois arrêts fois je rentre avec 4 me
tandis que trop braquer tous rue alors
qu'elle existe et que passeront projet
j'étais des cahiers c3 qui traîne aussi
et on sait ça recommence rd congo
terminèrent par tous les trois ça va pas
mal et peut-être la fougue et en
intermédiaires en premier la pour les
blancs non je vous mets donc je vais
faire du kayak à dire que tout est
attaqué par tous c'est n'importe quoi
c'est génial du crif qui est des six qui
a pris ce risque est hissé 3 way
ce proche de m
granby c'est donc à prendre deux roues
en f1 et retour en c3 c'est bien joué
whaou qui c'est quatre ou cliqué g62
quand ils vont revenir vers f4 qui va
faire avec les gens retour 17 mois un
peu d'autres la collection bruit
commence à puer non mais ça va être un
problème
ma tête ça les énerve aussi d'être mac
connecté tout le temps ouais je suis
plein les yeux plein de mecs énervé il
ya toujours la même tête aux pieds qui
est franchement je pensais à roye g4 nom
laisse france à l'idée d'un ticket pieds
jouent maintenant il faut tout reprendre
ah oui et cavaye aide mais non du cou
qui approchent paroisse g3 way i
et puis c'est tout qu'elle a peut-être
tour c1 et une en mai s'est pas fait
encore un nom n'est mieux non mais bien
sûr c'est mieux
d'ailleurs c'est pas gagné non pour 17
pts 3
donc à chier sucer pourquoi mes clés
ventura et des rois g3 pour un peu
partir ce cavalier ou cinq échecs mais
qui voulaient faire tu reprends des six
cavaliers f5 nuggets ont des tonnes
n'est pas cavalier 5 la voilà ce que je
leur ai tant qu'on dit inquiet pour
cette rechute
ifaith et 8 ouais parat en tant qu on
est inquiets procès 3 f kg 6 échecs et
entraîneurs boue et l'eau clairoix ont
eu quelques pins sacz bien ouais t'as
trash qui a quatre on suit pas fixée bon
bah je pousserai bien g5 j'aurais fait
rage quatre thèmes pour ici même
j'aurais même pas réfléchi en fait
ok tour siens wen en croit des sept
tours dire entier six tournées chez un
être abaissé à tour d un tour eiffe
cette tour des six tours cette tourbe et
6 passes a pu donc mais pas simple a
gagné en fait le malheur de renier
reggae tour ses six webisodes pas trop
fait mais je ne cède pas mal joué mais
je sais quand même ça veut dire que
c'est devenu très compliqué parce que
tout rebelle schiste en jetons combes et
simple qui est lui qui était tombé 6 3 5
attend il veut quoi by le roi des singes
vont te dire tu es d'échec la boue mais
du coup il se trompait j'ai fait
n'importe quoi en fait bah il se
trompait il ya des ménages2 pour rien au
monde quand même pas si simple mais vous
voilà on voit qui est une salle debout
dit bill williams et les pièces toulouse
sur les caisses de l'état mais ouais
dans le niveau de jeu un peu baissé côté
win
allez la rate l'ouverture en fait il me
répond cela se faisait plus de sens
bams et avec la connexion et c'est bien
vrai ça oubliez tout vaccin qui pousse
âge mais je trouve que c'est bien bien
joué ce qu'a fait oui de ramener le roi
là bas et de faire le contre jeu comme
ça parce qu'en fait le fou il peut bien
devenir cavalier ne changerait pas du
tout envie de faire il faut être quatre
vingts jours cette session qui lit ça
c'est leur rang de club 4 et des quatre
clés de machin aussi intrigué je mettrai
le fourrage de quand harry 24 ans dont
j'aurais jamais été avec emma 10 ans il
doit peut-être ferké les quatre
maintenant droit qui eux n'auront alors
qu'à renshaw je comprends qu'ils
reçoivent et si c'est bien joué oui oui
non je sais mais juste que c'est kevin à
lecavalier est super mal placé il en
diagonale par rapport au roi et à 3,8 en
bout et chargé son état général
ok mais j'ai cinq pas grave c'est cette
quête et 4 et fois je la prend 1,6
attend il laisse le fou et il va faire
dame croisée mossig et du souffle et
adam rage six ans elle fait mal ça là
pour bourges au pire un an depuis sa
dernière dernière de cadence au lieu de
tourner à -2 il tourne à moins 4 c'est
une grosse différence
ben c'est une grosse histoire mais c'est
hyper mis dans le choix d'avoir joué la
finale
avec le fou contre le gard et quand le
fou puisque jeu sur deux elle c'était
hyper dangereux fabre wayne quand tu
fasses pas tant baissé que partir du
moment où tu final que patrie l'été
psion beldame groupe de pure n 2 que le
tout évidemment c'est une question de
portée à la fois des tons bois c'est à
la fois défende le curage c'est ce qui
s'est passé et le cavalier hayes n'aime
pas les courses
enfin sur ce il est temps d'aller
déposer dans 5 minutes environ 5 à tout
de suite a tout de suite
[Musique]
20 40 m mais ce qui va refaire
4 non c'est un titre quant à l'heure
quand même ça ressemblait donc pas c'est
pas des mecs m'ont soit jusqu'à hu
[Musique]
oui je me demande je me demandais à
prendre le poste fabes que contre fierro
déjà il fait un match où il se fait
écraser
normalement non après par une lumière
dans ce format sur un échiquier je pense
qu'il est juste favori mais est ce que
là tu pense qu'il peut il doit pas trop
écrasé mais bon après je m'engage silviu
monsieur roch et je vous prends juste à
piéger sans aiguille compagnie les i
contre ok au prochain coup double donc
la réplique à 6 2 6 2 6 2 premiers sets
quoi bon toutes d'amd de d'un f4 le
noble face devant j'aime bien faire ça
l'exode peut elle est bien cette
manoeuvre
bah oui tu as même soirée quatrième des
heureux quoi devenir le roi 03 rock à
venir non il est fou et sept gardes le
fouillent je suis jamais forcément fan
de ce truc de garder flou
ouais vous est pas mal mais moi ça comme
ta bande espace tu poses y être content
de d'échanger sur un site d'amd deux
époux ici ouais je me demandais qu'est
pro 5 ou pas je n'ai peut-être qu'elle
prend qui les prend et jamy me fous des
quatre dom j'ai cinq sélections
législature
ça c'est pas terrible mais en fait
peut-être tel tu peux aussi faire un
petit fou les cinq agents un jour non
mais assez risqué de la réponse on écrit
sur lui même si j'ai perdu en clair
alors fou 17-15 ses cadres et voilà un
moment donné ouais ce peut être des
questions dans notre position ou quoi
d'autre c'est pas idiot cinq pieds
poings 5.5 ou rock nous je peux
peut-être quand même te prendras fils ou
de me prend je pense était hyper
dangereux femme non mariée qu'elle a 5
je peux comprendre qui est légal
bah j'aime pas du tout les noirs parce
ça va peser une menace d'être raciste et
le prime
ils vont enlever sa dame tupac et 6 4 je
pense que c'est à cette occasion ses 4
non merci je ferais bien en fait qu'à un
moment jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient baissé
qui veut partir prudemment g4 whelton
gens fragiles et fluide
pas si jeune bézy tête b6 ouais ok ok
maintenant un objet qui a défait revoir
je perds un jeu cette date
mais ok partez circuit c'est une tour
soit troisième faire du fric à tout mais
non tu as raison ça pourrait avoir si tu
fais tour celui tour c4 en plus j'étais
en train de me dire un moment donné non
maintenant trois coups ça empire épouse
est la meneuse je suis pas sûr parce
qu'il prend et faire cavalier c4 en fait
il faut toujours demander si louis s'il
est une idée de payer foot et 4 mais je
veux juste faire en même temps du très
grand même très bien joué je vais et
encaisser des six est fou d'elle afin de
les hisser comme hyper impulsif comme
décision parce que la nature alors
qu'étrangers 6 et 25 portées juste fou
tu es là ça va faire mal un fab lab mal
engagée fabre ça va faire mal
vendre forest qui est en train de passer
de l'orangé au rouge
un peu comme ta chemise je suis là
peut-être et prend des six mais bon il a
le temps et dame prend des cités gage
bas mais c'est dur pour eux pour le
néerlandais
tu peux t'on maintenant je vais tenter
quoi bon je vous prends quelque chose
j'ordonne grosse gaffe il faut ranger
ses membres monsieur ridicule du
cavalier quoi font à cette équipe et 2
je pense est faux pranger sept étages
sur un coup de cavaliers lambda ben tu
bouges tadam
du coup tour des 3 way un coup tu tombes
un prix est ce que le 5 cjue en fait non
reprise va peut-être prendre affaires de
m 5
ouais enfin n'en est peut-être sur deux
faces tu prends prend et d'un médecin
qui aurait kg 6 personnes d'abord g6
fous prochain arrêt du pendjab
oui donc c est ce que je t'entends
qu'elle fait de même 5 g 6 2 9 7 tours
j'ai cette prise le 5 prises aux cinq
essais mort est donc c'est fini ça va
encore faire un point pourra pour le
chinois
baldacci plus trop d'intérêts quoi je ne
te dire niveau suspense zapater tout cas
de voir des belles parties attente
encore quelque chose on my way
ouais non pas juste du terme
je pensais que tu ailles oui un caprice
prise il va récupérer à 2.242 français
de the way band forest a battu qui
devrait peut-être aller faire bûcheron
voyez des milliers d'euros en faisant
pucerons ah ouais enfin si j'ai un côté
ils font tous restent abattus
ouais ouais c'est rossi
t'expliquer troyes et tours france et 2
se faire plus simple vous +5 ça jamais
été remonté je crois dans l'histoire un
speech est ce un retour vers une femme
un homme resté reviennent voilà un vrai
choix enfin combien le dommage mais je
suis toujours partisan de faire du kayak
souquet 17 avait que cinq équipes c'est
simple tout ça très bien rentrer reste
ça c'est ça c'est du choix et 6,5 ha lik
ha 5 au prochain
cadets 2 à 5 dans mon g4 +17 comme ça je
inquiet ça donc il veut jouer notre jeu
fait pas qui c'est des trucs msis
toussaint ça tu ne fais pas non cela
n'empêche pas non mais c'est super dur
c'était recommandé dans le livre a
beaucoup trop niasse est indienne il
arrive très bon joueur mais je crois que
tout échec ce qui est de gagner quelques
bonnes parties et blanc dessus mais
c'est compliqué
ouais non on ne ferais ça qui doit à mon
avis et il est obligé de gagner non
c'est la haye au but de gagner pas mal
là maintenant autant qu'on serait plus
tôt possible
ces 5 ouvre tu peux faire un bon show
off français sont maintenant je me
demandais s'il souhaitait pas enfermé
mais respecte toutes les pressions que
je souffre la main ouais c'est plutôt
thèse ouverture ça ouais mais j'aime pas
qu'ils ont mais si tout ça c'est très
malheureux en fait cela mais je sais pas
trop comme des bouées de ce qui est des
cas peut-être que tu vas apprendre enfin
on nie tout reproche et cette menace
pour ça tu vas je crois pas trop en fait
ok on est très concret ce qui faire
confiance
ces cinq qui on prend 3 puis on prend b6
tu en prends des deux ça ce serait bien
parce que au moins le fou j'ai attiré
vers h si ses compagnes mais non pas
forêt soit france et 5
il veut faire des pro b 5 et auquel va
dire je bouge beaucoup choqué ses 8 qui
est des si c'est comme ça non mais bon
j'ai pas de concert célébrant donc un
coeur rouge et 4 ils ont échangé le fou
pour y ils vont tous les tours sont
chargés et on n'a pas la tacler la
montre et akena à trois ça m'étonne un
peu ce que vous avez 15 à 4 bonsoir fou
j'ai 4 a priori rien et tu prends de la
tour s'y prend ah ouais ok plus tard
voilà ce que j'ai souffert f3 c'était
seule chance pratique parce que tu es
fou h61 les questionnements moins bien
mais bon ok - t'as un fou qui joue tuku
ou cavaliers cessé le travail
donc là tu penses que les blancs sont
gueules noires mais fois justice en
bruit espère embrouille annoncé il
voulait faire tout ranger cette île
après tu en surnombre
alors attention n'ont d'égalés on est à
+ 2 tours angers un tapis de personnes
brahim est en surnombre ok bah oui mais
bon sang mais c'est imparable sur des
fois tu comprends pas que c'est très
problématique
1re fois ci sous le faire un jour là
pour éviter tout rejet cette voie là
vont rester nous mêmes ces mentions au
bac et noir là ça va ça tu vas garder le
fou et tu y défend dont j'ai trois
proches et 4 montant prend les est très
bons joueurs posent une surnombre mais
pas sûr qu'il le comprenne
du coup il prend le bus arrive trois
traits pleutre en fait il ne comprend
pas le surnom de docteur mais je ne sais
pas parce j'ai un fond qui peut ce
premier inclut blanc un monde
moi j'ai juste fait six tours j'ai trois
maisons -4
il faut ainsi ce truc comme ça tu vas tu
vas perdre à 3 ok c'est fini avec quoi
qu'il en soit je fais tout rejet 3 je
pensais d'eux enfin un peu toi tu vas
t'en prends bien avant je sais pas si tu
es si bien mais il va tenter d' american
dames c'est un des trucs
faites-lui m madame en a trois pour
empêcher dames c'est pas simple oubli de
se vanter de faire dame d'erdf 90 3 en
plus d'être un b3 b4 est la suite mais
la dame en c2 a aucune case entrée je
leur apprends v4 propres actes bah c'est
pas bête
je peux te faire roi prend b4
d'amsterdam prend à froid aussi p2 top 6
là tu fais tout à ercis ouais bah
bolides et je sais pas trop si
nivellement j'ai refoulé filles 3 b 3
pouces est simple grâce à son jeu prend
b4 bon en fait je comprends il va éviter
ces cinq je pense oui mais on s'en fiche
du coup de fil des six sont humides mais
bon tous réfutent les toits si c'est
dans la première des trois jours avait
même pris le tueur a trois enfants
mais pousser un question cette gestion
match ci fait nul ou justin et il a peur
bon on ne veut pas faire de nous rater
h4 qui est ce parce qu'en fait je pense
que les plans sont en effet la gamme
d'options plus est le pur à trois et il
peut au top de sa forme
après cachent pas qu'ils n'arrivent pas
pour le moment non enfin c'est qu'avec
les nantais ce que tu as pu surfer titre
en jeu suivant mais tu fus points
je vous fais une oreille de cavaliers
donc là c'est l'accueil des arrivants
des 3 tourne mal a donc rangé cette date
un jour fouchard d'envoi surnombre
besoin tu commences par roy prend 1,3
peut-être on va rentrer super sur
membres de 5,55 à jour jamais lassé de
tout au final il y avait 3 4 kg le roi
fou mais ya pas de maths mais bon c'est
pas si clair qu'est ce que c'est que ça
je pense qu'ils oublient roi prend 1,3 à
il s'est planté
mais bon des six n'ont pas encore quand
il ya du vent saingainy bontemps g5 1 et
1,5 et on annonce tout
comme ce soit mais bon foulée 6 échecs
bon les huit matches vous les six échecs
il faudra faire un jour mais on va
bouger de 5
une fois que 5e jouer c'est fini 5 et 6
voilà ce qu'on croyait jusqu'à des
quatre ans nouvelle victoire à là ça
commence à faire cher femme
oui c'était déjà cher mais s'avère de
plus en plus cher en fait une erreur de
prix peut même faire des à 17h à le fou
qui protégerait la casa futur a pas de
fourchette une rubrique un tremplin à 3
pts cette fois ci ah oui on va faire
comme ça a brassé 4 quai à tours fc et
ça fait plus cette femme non plus six
ouais mais oui je pense que le sort du
match en est jeté quoi les dés sont
jetés fab a eu la petite variante que
j'en recommande fab laquelle un oui mais
bon notre basse a fait écho à la vidéo
distancé paix strike j'ai le droit qua
non mais c'était c'est vraiment bien
jeux wii qui dominera bon de la tête et
les épaules fab un match qui manque un
peu de suspense 1 ne le cachons pas fab
ouais c'est bien cliqué au début
s'impliquer à crochets et puis tiens
moment est vraiment une course à
sarrebruck et c'était la cata s'arrêtera
après qu'il ait 2 2 c'était serré et
puis là en fait sur les valeurs faites
et l'aprilia pris 1,6 par kevin nury 6 0
et donc c'était mal tu te faut enchaîner
la foux ouais tu te rends chesnais mais
finalement tu vois ça ça ça veut aussi
un peu vous percevrez mais bon prague
ananda il est le match plus accroché
mais il faut dire qu'il a gagné quelques
parties sur des connexions 1
donc c'est vrai que ça fait vite la
différence paraît du coup en fait tu te
fais moi enchaîné mentalement c'est plus
facile
enfin ça change beaucoup de choses je le
souffle et que marre des pointes est
content ouais bah c'est ça ouais bon je
n'ai que les blancs et vassy de ces
quatre c'est un bolide et d'engins
s'occuper en fait pour animer la haye
les pions noirs est en groupe et à deux
comme ça ça va et en en isolant en fait
on sait bien c'est une question qui est
nous poser la question du jour est ce
que les joueurs d'élite aux échecs et
dans les autres disciplines doivent être
déscolarisés pour poursuivre leur
carrière
c'est la question du jour fable tu peux
réagir avec le hashtag speechless mais
qu'il vaut cette question cette chasse
points comme à la guerre bon d'accord je
me fais une autre de châtas nous ce que
je peux réagir je sais pas trop quoi
dire à sa question du jour qui aurait
quoi thèse antithèse tout ça on donne
juste un ami plainte du soleil
bah moi je te dis non
ok j'ai remis mon hockey non mais c'est
un avis qui est pris très cher en fait
on dort et twitté a speech shh suggère
une non hashtag non non tant pis
pourquoi dans le besoin est-ce que c'est
interdit les sceptiques qui demande n'en
attend également le monde si à
l'ouverture était imprécise pour les
blancs sa saveur d'aller très bien pour
le même là encore il ya beaucoup de jeu
en fait un clic hasard mais si la vie à
quatre je sais pas je trouvais que
c'était encore mieux parce que tu t es
pas toujours - tu allais faire la même
chose mais à moins que j'ai pas vu un
truc qui craque complètement en fait
l'abc joue vite en fait tu vois la syrie
de les jouer un centième 600e 900e 400e
fins et je joue tout tempo jeu prévu
mais il a montré une potion feront halte
au racket il pensait j'étais en train de
me dire c'est pas mal j'aime bien ces
géométrie athlé tour devient tout le jeu
mettrions ouais non mais j'aime bien
quand les pièces qui vont ligne droite
elle te contrôlant son côté au sol sur
le côté ray du cern tout le potentiel de
la pièce après peut-être d'un projet ici
s'est il fait sûrement avec les blancs
c'est en quoi nous estimer costis
tension le surnom de monsieur ben c'est
pareil sur calais froid qu'avait eu de
chance ouais bah c'est google qui croit
tout bien fait mais sur l'audi a5 comme
des boucs
advenant sur le faire tout reprend des
katas prend des quatre approches cinq
jours ne seraient pas directement le
surnombre sur htc pour c'est pour faire
un peu de spectacle le fab 2 on peut au
bout non mais effectivement on approche
empirique fessée mais au quesnoy là tout
va bien il y avait la tour avec
cavaliers jeudi avec un meilleur bond
mettre en scène 8 mai katsura quatre ans
prises bonton rentrant
pour la can tho reprend ses huit
médailles bronze et d'un proche simple
peut-être faire autre chose
surtout il est presque le double on vas
t'enfoncer de l'impossible dans le
proche 5 je pense est joué et environ 8
peut-être way d'un premier point s'ils
souhaitent un an maintenant j'ai pas
trop aimé nager quand je vais enlever du
clonage du il remet deuxième tour
géométriques presevo quoi c'est de la
pédagogie là je pense que c'est très
pédagogique
non c'est hyper pédagogique la femme
ouais ok eux cinquièmes 3 et perd 3,4
est ce que c'est les blancs qui sont mis
encore en bas on faisait bon rapport aux
modèles trop bizarre par rapport au
matériel est complètement faveur des
noirs mais le truc c'est que les
cavaliers sont super bien placé et les
pions noirs avancent pas du tout non
ouais mais bon le 5 c'était un problème
prise keyyo 5
jst ouais il peut pas se prendre un
cheapos de clouage à un moment donné
voici une offre partout et on écoutait
les chipeaux de deux tours à 4,2 mètres
du couloir de kiev cette destruction
partout de 17 ans mais bon quel point
aussi ce nom ouais ou du
ok mais de faire un coup de hache 600
des blues lorsque je préféré la jouer
avec les blancs mais je suis partagé non
la lingerie bon ça va prendre le cap je
prends ni les cavaliers d'en faire des
menaces autour du roi un fou et surtour
5 tu fais comment tu fais jamais de 4,4
franklin je pense même si ce vraiment
qu'ils la gagnent c'est la jolie ouest
alors j'ai trop usb 5 g si c'est pas bon
se faire très bien pour les blu ray mais
la dame t3 ya plus d'hommes je pense
qu'elle est nulle
segeco de choses sont adams était dans
une passe que le pion b en fait il
n'existe plus il se pourrait mais ouais
bon mais qu'un juge miley se bat
merengues j'essaye d'être un couple
étant fermée mais bon c'est injuste g5
tu te poses à échanger les pions et
discuter à tour sur le pion voici bien
domotique doc est venu riquet xv pardon
fausse alerte
niort ok je veux pas faire qui est
rangée 5 france la finale moi sur mon
nul
df 85 de chercher le plus intéressant 4
mondial
ok mais dupuy l'a réussi à gagner un
pion déjà c'est quelque chose que j'ai 4
c'était mal joué de la part des morts
actuellement il va faire de son mieux
pour liquider tous les tourments des
données la tour s'il faut cause ce qui
normalement est nul je pense que
purement a franchi la limite en courant
le gain théorique bon gars mais la
classe existe et 214 4 et en rangée trop
prochain bien joueurs ont bien défendu
c'était pas mal mais la crise totalement
dépassé et de loin - ivanovo quoi c'est
à dire google phone mais tu vois le truc
là par exemple why is a fait c'est la 2
troisième fois qu'ils sauvent tue elle
en a sauvé killer il en a sauvé une en
faisant nul très très résistant très
très très rose ouest parenti à des
sourcils e - - - touffu comment de
forest c'est un combat de sourcils en
fait ils pensent qu'ils aient cédé en
interprétant je pense moins que l'eau
soit des sourds cible travail en quoi la
chance je pense qu'il faudrait deux
sourcils et qui se fait défoncer en fait
je pense qu'il n'a aucune chance
mais vraiment au moins de 6 à 5 c du
tilt à cinq noms on voit un très bon bah
je sais pas si ça va mais ça a pas l'air
absurde c'est mieux comme ça que m'est
arrivé je suis pas con pas encore s'il
ya quelqu'un de cap j'imagine mais
encore faudra regarder ces racailles
prend des cinq dames barney en 18 chebah
duras je suis très bon line au script on
est un gâteau de fer en d4
mais bon on a pu faire dans le sens à un
moment il faut lancer cette même envie
cabrespine qui prend des cinq fours en
d5 dépend des pleins de bon sens la
patate
mais il est en train de dire c'est fou
la différence de niveau entre les tous
meilleurs en juniors c'est comme chez
les adultes ce que je vois que tu mettes
magoo louvain parham wifi rouge a
toujours vu en fait j'étais calme en
quarts de finale en fait sur fond de
fois il sait qu'à une partie des
meilleurs c'est pas un quart-de-finale
on est parti de 128 joueurs parce que
qq1 tour avant pas non plus ouais mais
les meilleurs qui ont été sélectionnés
oui donc bien sûr mais je veux dire
c'est pas un exploit en clair non plus
non mais c'est pas faux c'est idiot non
mais je suis d'accord avec toi là dessus
ça te fait raison mais je veux dire par
là que c'est comme un adulte servent que
la différence entre le numéro c'est pas
moi 11 12 mondial et le numéro un passé
que même si tu fais un match speech s je
sais pas moi non de cartes scène tu fais
un an de dung quât murat c'est un
carnage majeur c'est les mêmes carnage
en fait mais en fait c'est fou qu'à ce
niveau là il ya une telle différence
fait je pense il ya plus de différence
entre le 1 et le disque entre le 10 et
le 28 à ce que j'ai je pense avoir bien
mais c'est pareil au tennis genre tu as
plutôt différence que federer et est
numéro 10 et nishikori qu'entre n'y
changent rien 80e ouais c'est fou en
fait quand même la différence resserrée
qui sont toutes au dessus est un tueur
vous savez la glisse ben jawad il a rasé
web à 6 97 ou 4 6 6 1 6 4 6 4
bien dominé par 38 voix nadal devrait
bientôt arriver et a déjà gagné deuxième
set presque figé il peut la gagner
comment contenir le phrasé il appelle la
geekerie entrée au top 5 6 2 à efforts à
la tentation le devis pareil tu vois que
tu vois qu'ils favoris et du rush et
passionnant
tu devais donner un favori à nouveau le
coeur c'est rogers par les favoris de
pas de coeur quoi bon en fait quand même
depuis quelques années sur surface
rapide
bien dominé rogers aille jusqu'à roland
il a perdu en tassant sur terre ni porno
mais il a fait plutôt un match correct
voilà nadal trois fois donc là c'est
intéressant parce que nadal mène à être
en très bonne forme il joue bien un rôle
on est hyper bien joué là ici massacre
tous ses matchs donc dur à dire mais ça
peut très bien vraiment un bon match là
bas parce que juste pour moi il est il
est vraiment favori nadal
rodgeur rodgeur mais je sais pas nadal
échoue enfin je serai ça intéressant en
tout cas ouais ouais carrément bon alors
c'est au parti rouge de remettre mon
score je serais content pour lui non
mais ce sera très chaud
non mais je pense produire favori tour à
quatre peut-être tout la géométrie feu
nourri tous mes chances qu'elle te plaît
si la tumeur est très mal ait failli se
fait défoncer
bats toujours ne fume plus toi c'était
pas mal ça va mais je sais pas pourquoi
on devrait de m il ya aussi le temps qui
joue en faveur du du néerlandais n'a pas
encore avec qui j'en ai gagné une en
remontant le rang hcc a pas très
longtemps et j'ai bu lui le tweet ouais
alors n'hésitez pas à les voir
l'interview de maxime qui n'a pas trop
marché fasse finalement j'étais un peu
déçu les gens qui ont lu était heureux
et où il ya des bons commentaires et de
ça mais juste un sens que les gens se
désintéressent un peu ils ne vont pas
bien a surtout qui a pas que la lecture
il ya des filets partie intéressante
analyse et barbra les jeunes on les fera
il ya cinq très belle partie iii les
meilleures parties de maxime selon ses
dires c'est pas moi qui ai inventé bien
oui c'est bien parti et plus de parties
dont une très célèbre kasparov topalov
ou ignorants balade à fond et une autre
partie de ghetto que je fais c'est
pâques est pas mal du tout outre kashima
est-ce que tu rendras finale de pions
avec un changement ou pas c'est est ce
que c'est si c'est choquant choquée fab
1 million 30 route de 10 secondes 80 kms
que tu enfin la finale de pions et run 5
déjà en fait tu la gagnes par le caire
est super ce avec les noirs tu dois je
suis à disqualifier quoi il souffle non
mais il souffre à ben non mais il
souffre pas mais comment tu perd sa
femme
comment tu peux me rajjou dégoûté il
fera ceci cela même pas évoquée par
brandon par toi tu perds tout par
forfait c'est fini mais tu sais quoi il
est moins bien faire sa ba fait le faux
débat évidemment tu peux pas perdre ça
quoi non non mais il aimerait bien
partir
non mais là c est le format qui fait
qu'on te force à rester ce que le mec
qui croit encore et oui je vais remonter
bombay qui a fait reconnu loeb peut
tomber ses choix
le pont mais bon il a fait nul mais bon
c'est incroyable voilà il ya des spots
pour fermer le nom mais il est plus
famille non mais liées plus nommé basse
et quand as-tu fait 1 2 me sur 7
clairement c'est que ça va plus loin
c'est dur qu'on puisse calmer mais oui
le format bon ce qu'on a toujours dit on
n'aime pas on veut faire dès cette es1
monde on a perdu mais oui le second
temps mais en fait c'est parce que les
échecs le baiia aucun sport individuel
comme ça dans des matchs qui se jouent
en temps c'est c'est les sports comme le
foot le basket ou quoi ou d'une marque
c'est lassant point que le lendemain et
se rafraîchir se voit pas mais je
n'entends moi j'en connais pas le record
de l'heure en vélo elle aime le vélo en
fait c'est pas en temps 100 km quand ils
font leurs corps de leurs amis leurs
corps de l'arrêt annoncé un événement
une fois tous les trois ans oui
heureusement su peu arrêté en mai
c'était trop tard une roulerai pas
vendeur que dégage
ce quelque chose oui non ma fille tu vas
le truc c'est que déjà témoin fort et à
l'aspect moral à quoi qu'il va un moment
tu sais que vous voilà tu attends juste
la femme fête et de faire autre chose
mais bon ce qu'on a déjà dit sur plein
de matchs en fait ce sera chez les
juniors les femmes les hommes les noms
binaire et je pense que format niña ben
ouais l'idée très bien mais il ya un
moment où évidemment si star de cette ou
en points à quoi doivent de forêts soit
ça sera le droit de quitter le match en
fait garder en temps mais rôle droit
d'abandonner le premier à 12.6 assure
enfin si vous faites mais oui j'ai
l'impression qu'il y ait pu non plus pas
dû agir sans que les parties sont très
décousue un an expliqué prenez 4 ça
marche bon jeu ben si je te prends doute
elle me regarde et je sais pas je me
suis pas trouvé la peine de chicken ça
juste leur faire enfin une découverte
mois voilà mon pote en bouger adam je
prenais fuite
oui mais banks mais oui mais pas d'avoir
récupéré une qualité pas je faisais
quand même illusion qu'un cahier prends
ça ait pris la fuite vers l'est en fait
si tu es fou prend des quatre reprises
et 4 passes tu peux en vendre et déjà à
réduire sa montre qu'il n'y a plus du
tout by the adoption - un peu fou
qualité non obligatoires mais bon je
vous reprends g7 mais moi oui des
catastrophes moi je ne porte que le coût
n'a lui il vint qu'elle prend des cas
comme ça c'est pas dur à voir
non mais je n'ai d'ailleurs très
impulsif qui jouent tous tempo en fait
il s'en fout il a craqué bayrou c'est
normal aussi on ne peut pas lui jeter la
pierre
les petits poneys qui nous dit que c'est
le rappelle au cas où il fait noir est
encore pire et 28 à 2,7 à 2,8 me deux
nuls max et le match de demain c'est
quoi du coup c'est magouille contre
contre pied contre sarah n'a un bond à 1
à grand favori ouais ouais il y aura pas
match nul
pourquoi pourquoi pour l'organisme ah
non je pense que la voiture ici plein
cours déjà très facilement ben taeb adam
3 aussi saâdane autour des 8 3 7 kg sa
as et puis commence avec tour ces deux
très bien à tous leur une finale c'est
bien je l'étais de prendre des pièges
des matches 6 après orange et ça tout
les défendre tordre et des
investissements
et puis l'a5 1 4 c'est fini
[Musique]
cette couche à affaires +7 fab
ouais non mais bon là bien sûr je
connais ta pour le match mais c'est dur
ouais non sarah n'a pas apprécié
préemption ouais cet espace froid et
c'est mon projet était très possible
avant donc bon je reviens pour en
progrès ce qui qui qui qui fuit sur un
score correct surtout sen par brat là où
je me suis dis pas clichy est fatigué
saint-palais bongo et une fois bac
attend que ça passe 2006 comme hélas
vrai mais bon pas cher si paris en
journée mais zidane fait ça fait déjà
deux trois ans qu'il avait 17 ans tu
vois il est dingue et lucas du cahill je
pensais qu'ils étaient moins forts mais
bon dix dates stopper sa progression
donc j'appelle de 2006 à mai mais un peu
comme à paris
enfin tu vois ça ils seront pas elles
seront jamais champions du monde
non ça c'est sûr mais même 25 ans on n'a
jamais rien pas de chance car tu as tu
as peut-être monter un jour avant à 2700
avec un gros rush mais ce sera un joueur
genre green jones powell tout ça à pas
les onglets comme ça qu'il s'est déjà
très bien évidemment du monde vient de
faire aussi mais n'est tu seras jamais
menaçants pour les vautours
ouais mais ça arrive souvent c'est pour
ça que c'est difficile quand vous êtes
jeunes ou quoi est ce pas parce qu'il ya
un gamin qui arrivent comme toujours la
wifi roue du champion du monde ma
charrette charles est très fort je sais
jamais vraiment jusqu'où ça va aller
pour jouer avec n'importe quand pour le
truc de la legal ou pas je te dirais
plutôt valais comme quoi joue jamais
pointé après touba qu'on recommande
plutôt l inverse de faire du rap non
d'être calibré et hésiterait utilise en
fait en fait se dit le savoir est une
arme
mais il n'a pas fait d'études donc il
est calibré en fait la plateforme frais
va en fait il faillit pense que c'est
peut-être fugitif en fait qui peut plus
elle fait plus mal avec un bazooka qui
accueille quelque une plume horaires
veux toi il te dis mon associé une plume
tu cries délivre enfin c'est intéressant
mais en fait bon moi je suis calibre est
donc radio ça peut être un autre conseil
fatah dans le dans le futur le sur la
chica score en fait ça manquait quand
même là bas ok tu peux partir coup
double en disant ça mais globalement en
fait je veux dire oui c'est toujours
très dangereux de mettre tous ses oeufs
dans le même panier
et quant à 12tu raison d'arrêter l'école
je pense à cet arrêt tu sais pas comment
tu as déjà évolué haïtienne face chez
accor
juste avant de blessures sur nos échecs
je sais pas ce que c'est vraiment la
blessure secrète juste en a marre du jeu
la met à paris des gens qui ont
maintenant je reste un sujet c'est fin
tu pensais que ce serait tabou
non c'est pas ta vous mais t'as pas mal
de gens qui ont cru aux échecs qui en
ont marre de jouer aux échecs
non mais en fait c'est vrai qu'à un
moment sur une chose est en fait la vie
de progrès que battu par tout le temps
tournoi à droite à gauche ou des parties
du jeune parti de jude est parti se
prépare est urgent ou tu rejoues tu
rejoues est en fait faut toujours être
motivé sur sa le vôtre olympique tu peux
pas jouer comme ça comme peut-être je
sais pas tu préfères les emplois de
bureau ou sa demande pas trop d'être à
fond pas tu fais le tu as fait ça va
vous échec je ferai le taf tu peux
vendre c'est pas comme si tu avais juste
à rester en ouverture haute voix c'est
une ouverture tous les jours trop fou
mais j'adore faire créatif à un moment
et a pu le la force l'envi le mojo ouais
non mais t'as plein de joueurs en fait
carrément joue moins bien aujourd'hui il
régresse en fait mais alors qu'ils sont
censés être plus fort c'est plus
d'expérience plus de connaissances plus
de trucs et ce côté mojo que tu as plus
en fait il est très bon ce que disait
mohamed ali et quand il te dit the
wheels better than the skin il exagère
un peu ce que pense tu sais pas mettre
un coup de poing avant tout will que tu
veux
mais mais qu'en fait oui genre à un
moment c'est ça que je fais rend la
science et gens soient en fait être
envie de mettre des coups de feu
entendus vous êtes en train de nous dire
ah bon j'ai plutôt envie de tout point
là un bout plus jamais fait c'est un
vrai problème pour les sportifs de haut
niveau en fait cette motivation et que
en fait pas de même des mecs très très
fort pas un genre beauregard était à 26
août à nice parce que je pense ce
n'était pas un côté physique
zidane car à 33 ans
donc tu vois de coupe du monde fut en
2006 study milan ac en plus joueuse mais
juste bon c'est bon t'as déjà tout fait
à tout donner
il y en a marre a tout gagné quoi les
mares aussi ou alors tu prends le truc
parce que tu sais que viendra jamais
rien aussi si jamais jean st gelais
pendant que je sais pas profiter les
bandits quand on sent que les lâches et
la ferraille la lâcher il sera toujours
un bon joueur il fait ces stries machin
très bien mais en fait dans les cordes
il a fini dernier mais qu'il a joué des
gambie d'amis fêter foncé entre carl
scène et caroit nature différence de
près par raymond lévesque convient
championne du monde à comparer c'est pas
une critique c'est juste l'acte et donc
voilà il passe la main et chasser stream
va être marrant il fera du tournoi kong
est il sera de mettre un peu l'eau
shoichi qu'oui peut machin mais voilà en
fait la boîte très fort un moment tu tu
salage quoi il menacera les gens qui le
bat règles et donc quoi j'ai quand même
une admiration pour le mec qu'on fait la
longévité en planant d'incroyables qui
se battent encore là maintenant il est
moins fort c'est tout mais s'il faut que
je la trouve sa chronique et doit très
longtemps vont ils arrêter maintenant
voilà et c'est pour ça qu'à sport aussi
je suis admiratif attendez moi un
mondial c'est juste fou la carte scène
on trouve c'est un croate qui fait et
c'est incroyable mais c'est pillon
climat mondial 2010 ou 2011 mais oui
énorme mais c'est 7 80 53 fois et tu
pourras rejoindre paris ouais c'est
juste fou
et donc c'est le problème ce côté
motivation et voilà pour ce genre les
nadal federer tout cas c'est fou mais
djoko est basse un an
mais oui quand il fait n'importe quoi
pendant d'autres en scène il est revenu
en fait mais je pense qu'il le
contrecoup de juste et pas qu'en match
lancé contre vous quand elle avait
réalisé son objectif de gagner plus
quand même grand chelem chez huawei
et ça l'a épuisé mais c'est incroyable
ce que vont de forêt c'était vraiment
pas mal et là et non mais lol bah non
c'est dur c'est dur mais vraiment mais
tu en parles on flingue a saisi que là
il aimait pas le tennis et joussaume et
s'associe extraordinaire fait numéro un
mondial sans aimer le truc bas d'autre
qu'à man is miami les candides et pichet
que c'était la souffrance à son père le
faisait jouer à fond aux entraînements
entre d'entraînement notamment c'est que
tu aimes pas le dis ce que tu aimes bien
niveau mais c'est ce qui peut se passer
aux échecs pour des gamins quand on
parlait de ça je pense la qualité des
parties a quand même baissé vraiment
pratiquement wall e je me pose est ce
parce que je parle à jour là je parle
mieux c'est plus parce que bien sûr à
d'autres faits dames où veux tu prends
d'ailleurs est un beau champion
les gens pour ses victoires à 2 et
change to win qui arrive au ski ac33
bien pour moi c'est pas grave en fait
non mais bon c'est juste grâce de ce
procès mais ok mais à tour ses cinq
prendre ses citoyens il faut il prendre
de 5 d'un millier plus hâtif f4 outre
ces quatre noms ouais j'ai dit à 13 15 f
4g 4 4
evra prend 1,4 otan prévu la gaine des
g5 non mais c'est fou c'est cadeau
l'arctique est incroyable comment le
mental ça peut jouer sur sur le niveau
de juin bah ouais mais ça ça tu
l'empêchent de dormir pendant une
semaine s'il est motivé il lui que le
fait encore qui ça bon de forest gérait
tulle mais là tu lui fais faire nuit
blanche tu le réveil tout le temps tu
mets la position il fait nul quand même
ah ben oui c'est fait il fait ça les
yeux fermés mais cette flotte est plus
un peu de limites j'ai en fait j'étais
absent qu'inconsciemment tu cherches à
te prendre des trucs way qui m'arrive à
moi en fait quand j'en pouvais plus que
tu japon que tu fais exprès en fait de
mal foutu les pieds sera plus là ça se
voit son visage serait il a les
pommettes rouges chance pour le tuméfié
quoi bas mais c'est chaud non mais je
trouve c'est un peu moche de force à
jouer mais parce que c'est c'était la
torture en fait c'est ça et surtout pour
le genre d chacun oui je pense j'ai déjà
dit une fois mais en fait on n'a pas
l'habitude bien au foot tennessee 0
battu fait fin du match et puis
peut-être encore 1 h 02 c'est horrible
c'est comme ça le brésil en demi-finale
enfin c'était tellement ils te barrer
métier t'as pas le droit et depuis que
tu es jeune c'est comme ça là mais bon
on est peut être c'est quand même une
différence c'est qu'il n'ya pas 300
minutes de jeu non non bien sûr mais je
dis oui mais c'est quand même des sports
- enfin gens là ces trois heures et
demie femme sans les pauses c'est 3h45
où tu te fais défoncer dieu sait qu'un
différend non nos déchets qd tu peux
faire des parties de huit ans non mais
géré la le formal apprécié ouais ses
vertus d'asile
roger chèque en fait on on abandonne
antoine est en fête
le match est donc fait normalement on
abandonne sa joue plus quoi on n'a pas
l'habitude de ça c'est d'autant plus dur
parce qu'on n'a même pas cette habitude
année ok mais y'a pas avoir l'habitude
et devoir rejouer encore 30 de plus il
n'ya pas avoir l'habitude et devoir se
taper 1h45 de match face aux russes ils
ont le sourire
wen a fait genre le speech est une bonne
idée mais pour arriver m ce système de
points en place pour ou d'abandon de
match
enfin là c'est juste triste de le voir
continuer en fait c'est l'ombre c'est
l'ombre de lui-même
pierre mongin il ya 2006 il est jeune et
il a déjà fait des parties s'est attaqué
cette année là vous inquiète le carnage
total on peut dire qu'ils allaient donc
ça pas forcément de rapport
ok je cherchais le jeu de mots je n'ai
rien n'avait pas en fait c'était un
piège
c'était un piège d'autant plus puissant
en retrait puisque j'étais la suite on
perd je cherchais je trouvais pas il
reste que je dois répondre je sais plus
c'est génial en fait c'était un piège
confié quoi paf il est et pourquoi pas
ce que ça donnait l'impression qu'il ya
un truc à comprendre
cinq des dents longues quel dans wave un
goûter était pris de vitesse quoi et du
coup on avait dépassé mais dans le piège
pas senti qu aucun rapport je faisais
des tiers la mûre tu as comme ça ce qui
rigolaient à toutes les blagues en fait
du coup je faisais des fautes vague des
juifs est là fallait pas rire face
c'était pas drôle en fait c'est pas de
lag mais me fasse tomber dans les pièges
toi toi non pas sa langue maternelle non
plus mais bon c'est bon quand même
tu me dis là est dans l'ombre en kazakh
peut-être que je rigole oui peut-être
encadrex était drôle tu vas pas pour le
coup complètement
non mais j'essaye de raconter n'importe
quoi parce que je sais pas quoi dire en
fait face et l'agent hms que le kazakh
est très différente du rustique oui
complètement
ses avocats rappelé en terrassant très
longtemps a refusé de parler kazakh murs
être la version casaque de du libanais
quoi enfin la moitié liman et je suis
blanc plan sur le même temps cependant
très fin ses parents comment suivre ça
soit tu te dis qu'il européen d'accord
oui mon problème pape sy
j'aime un grand-père en vampire oui f 3
kg 3 la new wave 3 3 3 tout méchant bon
et nous les prenons à 7 et puis on verra
bien j'en ai tellement désespérant comme
position beaucoup furent un échec ou pas
échec cette fois
en fait je crois qu'il est vraiment
titre total va observer ziv crée une
menace en un coup mais c'est rare
j'ai pas trop compris le titre à chelsea
sir pour un geste y seront remontés de
ses chances je voulais faire ton g8
cavalier e set peut-être fou des deux
îles qui tapait de plongée 4 et
l'empêcher tournage de tours h un match
enfin on est d'accord c'est bien vrai ça
tu veux juger trois au prochain et ça à
faire + 9 ah ben ouais faut plus compter
des points et vous faire cavalier trop
gay venait de faire quelques tours
seulement kg 3e menti ouais mais en fait
3e inscriront oui c'est drôle comme
étant peut-être bon il nous le fait le
g3 attractive il s'amuse en fait soyez
il a trouvé une souris quoi c'est un
chat
à dégage je ne vais pas te tuer je joue
avec toi dégage
ah merde il est mort enfin l'influencé
très très déçu quand imad est offerte et
à sa cave a lieu deux tours prend qui on
prend encore apprendre à caser un
effondrement mais la caisse francilienne
ouais j'ai tout de suite eu lieu ces
deux noms mais on compte les points
quand même famille en art art mada de
compter les points ce matin christophe
mais sa santé un canton et vu le premier
match sont et foretz tard il était quand
même bien moins fort que tout le reste
non mais on espérait que la collection
saute pour un bon club pour équilibrer
ouais ça on a toujours ce qu'on a dit
dès le début le chancelade de cordage
est très solide bah ouais non mes débuts
en avion on avait bien placé quand même
voiture on avait fait un bon résumé du
match pas facile et si oui une bonne
connexion ne regardez pas ça ne sert à
rien le ça est un massacre mais si la
connexion saute ça a été un match très
intéressant quoi a du coup très bonne
analyse femmes
merci benzaie aux délices que oui on
espérons que le cordage de federer car
ça chaque point très intéressant quoi
oui s'il se blesse un petit peu qui se
tend légèrement la cheville ça
rééquilibrera les chances normal en fait
comme celle 6-0 6-1 6-2 et quand tu dis
oui je joue encore 4,7
parce que c'est comme ça c'est terrible
ça m'étonnait jamais inquiets reste qui
reste quoiqu'on dise ont des consignes
oui je sais les ranger avait peut-être
un pompier bon en fait tu t'es fort je
veux le faire est de permettre au oui
non et je sais pas si bas news dans une
telle situation il partait elle serait
très très énervé les gens y viennent à
équiper un blitz ouais je sais plus et
quand les prix maximum 8 fallait
plusieurs fois la retraite au norwich
est je suis pas quoi et a perdu il
jeter sa chaise perdu arbitres se dégage
on savait le troisième de suite
maxime mais bon il y avait zéro en jeu
cette amicale ouais bah du coup j'ai pu
vivre un mondial en blitz mais bon la
belle affaire c'est quand même beaucoup
de l'importance qu'il a réalisé à côté
tout ça met d'ailleurs en finlande il a
gagné autour de suite du coup on ne
compte pas comme un tournant après celui
c'est vrai parce qu'en fait c'est pas
vrai c'est une victoire d'affilée non
non remettre en cause tout une tout
autre nature gagné que deux de leurs
banques que c'est génial en fait
puisqu'en fait du coup il s'en remet
tout en cause chère que tu ne considère
pas sans abri
ça veut dire que tu ne respectes pas les
organisateurs en fait même si on
considère que les tournois qu'on gagne
et si j'en ai gagné 25 de suite que
c'est génial il faut absolument
connaître un tweet tweet quoi je faire
un tweet
non mais tu as raison faut absolument
faire un truc là dessus en fait ça on
remet tout en cause
la fête ses 80 qui a compté pour le
classement elo en blitz et le méritent
vraiment bien c'était d'art un truc
officiel c'est un tour officiel est pas
le fait qu'il y les tournois l'an waimes
alors jeté des champions du monde
de quoi me remplit tous de quoi la
rapide ouais ça compte dans les huit
choix
mais du coup de match en classe du monde
car la scène car ça compte aussi
bah non parce qu'il a été champion du
monde au blitz non mais j'ai dit le
champion dents longues
le match aura t il et pas dans les huit
au cou parce que sinon ça compte pas ce
qu'il va pas gagner enfin il a gagné en
rappelant qu'il a payé il a fini premier
ex-aequo ouais ouais non mais en fait je
crois qu'en général c'est ce que cette
joie des tiers personne dans la base
j'ai bien fait ce sur quoi ils comptent
quatre as encore ce qu'on remet en cause
dans tous les cas on s'en fout même si
on a tort ménard est en cause pas on
mettra d'abord deux fois ouais ouais
donc la presse il a gagné le grand de
gestour croatie l'a gagné ouais le
tournoi avant la wii c'est un truc en
fait inutile c'était le truc dans
l'habit et ben voilà lui compte paypal
autres le abidjan grand prix film mais
meridian et c'était dur rapide
oui mais ça vous arrive pas le classique
ouais maria le gâchis mof ouais tata
steel
ouais et je peux du monde de blitz à
saint pétersbourg sa fille manon avec
tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est ça ouais tu
vois que vous comptez tout se fait trop
mal et qu'il n'a pas gagné pareil banon
mais du coup un jeu régulier sur twitter
c'est qui paye cher si je recompte bien
mais je crois si nos richesses ça fait
deux voici nos richesses l'abbaye
abidjan oui la vie en plus faf abeilles
abidjan si green gables compte ou quoi
gashi ma tata steel
les huit le but when ont évoqué mais il
compte ce qu'ils veulent en fait face et
c'est grave dans les échecs on sait même
pas faire des statistiques
alors oui on va à djokovic de saison et
les élèves seront ils et 75 matchs
d'affilée enfin gérard celui que tu
perds ouais merde ça ne vont pas
celui-là non je te promets surface
ouais je ne compte pas précisé alain de
tout remettre en cause en fait non mais
je vais twitter no fake nombeux je te
crois un toit un tel match le tout peint
en fait je sais pas tomber la torah la
bible
allez une victoire pour jo qui madame g
s'agissait là mais on revient pas c'est
génial il ne voit absolument rien le
niveau de jeu est calamiteux quoi ce
génial quand on regarde les parties
vitrées en fait mais j'ai l'impression
que ça fait très mal
tours a des limites on déjoue drop it or
not going on s'est tellement envie de
gagner
et justement si se veulent autant il
peut en une chance de perdre sa gamme
une tour qua non mais c'est à voilà à
leur tour leurs ventes à valence et -8
seulement 4 piètre niveau de jeu ça fait
pas mal et je twitte quoi ces partis
direct femme tu as commencé je fais mon
tweet voix l'attention matin avec deux
c'est bon on a bien défendu a fait 10 4
bien qu'elle ne songe et je pense qu'ils
g3 varient mais voilà your way cette
solution compliquée attendu mais moi je
prends on s'ouvre nos colonnes je vais
en réalité magnus car c'est la gagne et
quand je twitte n'a gagné que deux tours
dans le filet elles n'ont donc deux
points d'affilée
en effet un truc très sérieux en effet
le tech 3 peut-être trois pots de 30 ans
l'europe est comme le bolide c'était
avant c'est là qu'elle vienne leur
richesse après l'es8 croatie et machin
non non non mais non mais non mais c'est
l'abbaye c'est apps et entre les deux la
vie maintenant je sais pas je roule je
n'ai que deux du coup je twitte en effet
maxime vachier lagrave dégageait bl
alors on the site avait gagné le tournoi
de blitz de la halle t-box et là je vais
te mettre hashtag est là je vais te
mettre hashtag fake news et acheta tchac
tchac facs je dire je vais aller très
très loin ce que c'est une fête nous
attendons c'est interdit en france et
chaque fac ce tag le gouvernement qui a
pas aidés nous quoi cet axe et là je
suis très heureux et consolide ses le
tweet le plus con du truc
en effet il avait gagné nos richesses
un besoin de blitz du norwich est ce une
embrouille chase si vous voulez donner
du poids sweat shop est allé le lac et
niro twitté le veilleur du truc était
mettez de l'engagement dans ce tout
gamin j'ai oublié de l'oublier de mettre
le hashtag no fake bontempi manger mais
j'ai vite fait que news jamie fox news
je ferai que je rajoute un trump quoi il
fait dit ouah fait que news corp très
énervé tu travailles pour sienne en
dégage je lui qui a déjà recruté passé
c'est génial en plus on a raison quoi
s'est fait fort quoi le franchisé de
pause il ya plus de pluie qui dînent
objectif de kem essaie de recueillir une
menace de mort de la part de tout le top
10 des échecs enregistrés les gens là
mamar presevo si on fait les flancs de
retweet de partout non mais faut bien un
peu trop alpha ben voilà avec quoi
combats à l'est conclusion alors quoi je
parle pas du tout que ça on est maîtres
fous des six damage de toi et fuite
enfin je renvoie ouais mais un petit peu
fer d'amérique
non mais ce serait faut qu'on change ton
article en fait de terminale bep est ce
que tu as et minuit tour en faudrait
mettre 2 ouais mais toujours de mettre
publie monteur way famille vit des
informations suisse eper d'articles avec
toi tu t'énerves après tu dis oui j'ai
écouté la propagande a fait est très
très nerveux aussi quel média peut-on
encore écouter nos jours ouais je te
faisais confiance
[Musique]
bon tout prendre quatre cépages suite
appelé ppf lippi pfl quoi j'ai déjà tout
j'ai mal et je reviens une deuxième fois
que la chanson est plein de chez moi que
le titre fasse que se fasse remarquer
quoi c'est génial si le titre fait
remarquer que l'on vérifie qu'on a
raison et c'est vrai dans la raison bah
oui avec quoi seront tous préparent
alors que l'habit compte objectivement
bah oui mais c'est génial et des noms
qui écrivent des 48
magnus carlsen des explications à son
tour c'est simple je veux y en a marre
et joby
louis joppy vous joppich géoparc pas
joppy gioi les et guy jolly un enfer est
pavé à 20h quand même un jeu hôpitaux
pourquoi à ils font pas pleurer c'est un
interdire pleutre voilà antoine est
empreint des 5es joplin en france et 6
donc voilà je crois je suis moins sûr
tant qu'on sait si ce n'est pas non mais
envoie de france et site d'un match de
folie vivalis et le journaliste
norvégien bat agh et le écouter un
hasard je m'achète n'est-ce pas
phaidon défaut ce stade enfin j'en ai
marre non mais en fait c'est vraiment
une focus du coup pour la peine sans
rire en fait bon bah alors oui c'est une
dame g3 d'alger 3 fable oui le match et
dames et toi top g3 seimat ab allaient
voit le jeune femme il a vu là il a vu
et c'est la 8e victoire d'affilée
shopi oui c'est ça joe fille qui mène
qui mène 5-0 fac dans ce match
extraordinaire jo petit oui au fond du
trou
[Rires]
qui l'eût cru avant le match comme tel
scénario mais ça c'est la pause quoi là
dessus c'est la pause prêt relais sur ce
5-0 pour jouer aux billes oui ici ici
c'est arrivera pas tout du jour bon du
coup on fait la petite pause n'a les
cieux un problème dans cinq minutes
on refera évoluer le twin fortier plus
sonatrach loi
[Musique]
bon c'est reparti les mecs ça rejoue on
a quand même il a restauré et réponse de
target qui nous confirme bien qu'ils
considéraient pas fable que le ton à 2
beat c'est un tournant fait donc bon
match devant mettre un concert ce qu'on
veut coiffer ce que caruana est champion
du monde
ban est peut-être qu'on considère que
tous nuls en tant que challenger tu as
gagné tu arrives il est unilatérale ou
quoi bon tout cas ce but là tu vas pas
ce que tu penses que plus cette micro
chance pour revendre forest bah si le
cordage t-il un nom mais son cordage on
ne sait pas bon tout cas oui à changer
de premier coup et j'ai eu 4 et 1 8 h
d'or et puis mon dernier
voilà bon là ça sert d'être très bien
pour un banc de poissons qui a gagné un
pion calme chez hogan même si on perd en
qualité c'est pas grave parce que le
kavé très fort surtout très saine ayessa
là ils vont être versé un peu faible
tout cas ça ajouterait reste on est dos
tout ça envoie du coup je suis on dirait
qu'on joue sur deux wimbledon n'ont
d'ailleurs l'échiquier vert ouais bah
voilà c'est pour ça qu'il est si ce prêt
ou f5
bon allez noirs sont mieux femmes 1 je
pense après ce que c'est vraiment peur
les tours de suffisant ait oussa four
est ce que rend de la qualité peut être
unis dans mon dos n'est peut-être
n'est-ce pas plus pour retarder
l'échéance qu'autre chose parce que je
veux ou tu veux la rendre plus contre un
pion on compte finalement un homme a été
battu retard et va faire ton c quatre et
cinq sets très bien il peut il peut
revenir à moins six femmes et après
qu'est ce qui peut se passer dans la
tête du joueur chinois façon moi je
considère que ce match se jouera que sur
le bullet avance ne comptait pas pour le
match à la thune et là je perds une
belle info fab
donc voilà qui comptent triple morton
double d'être blanche à cga la lettre
blanche ce cratère le joker
tu es tout ce que tu veux ouais mon la
fabia trois pions maintenant pour pour
la kalach
j'ai envie de dire jopik est en train de
manger qui est en train de manger
joueurs chinois intentions attention il
va alors six points d'écart le match
semblait gagnée pour le chinois
c'était sans compter les meubles et mon
break deux dans ce cade tour à 4 wen a
besoin cuma se passe est trop appuyée
fourchette sur des cas tout est dit que
venir dans le stream qui viennent estime
jim hines de dire bonjour que je vous
dois payer un jour j'aimerais tellement
météo mignonne angie sympa hein
ouais et l'horizon de jodie banjo qui
revient femme jolie qui semble
inarrêtable continue oui qui est un peu
sorti du match à penser que son
adversaire a été blessé et la paix il
avait fait un appel aux petits nés en
fait il a juste lâché un set comme ça il
regarde quoi font manger trop de jus
mais c'est génial en fait je prends et
je prends vers lé elle dégage
et promet 5 ou reprendre en prend à 5 ou
5 vous n'êtes pas monsieur prend 5,4
mais safran au coup est parti tout à
l'heure en fait les mines à tour ans et
5 tout ça mais il vient un moment donné
avec et noir je sais pas si on dit
d'emblée oui il montera sont autant
répéter l'expérience tu as gagné tu
rejoues après ça veut dire que tu
comprends tu semblais à aulas
le prévenu qui fait mal et c'est dommage
c'est moi qui avais tu vois c'est sûr
fenat -5 tu vois tu passes devant que
ouais il aurait cette série de 14
victoires d'affilée mais bon il peut que
reprendre pour une 15e victoire
d'affilée femmes
on l'a complètement s'est défait sur
pressure surpris move ça compte ou pas
d'abord ça qu'on pas ok donc ton
expertise là en tant que grand mais tu
ton expertise tient coi messieurs qu'on
nomme bondam top des 6 mhz ouais mais ça
lui a fait mal aux joueurs néerlandais
fab wci ségur et reste quand il reste 24
minutes par et qu'il essaye de tenir sur
le en plus un quoi
l'hymne à 2,0 ou steak le première clean
c'est que la première mais il était sur
une série avec deux victoires en trois
plus un tueur à ivry bobos ou saint
pacôme cous
mais est-ce que c'est sûr que ça marche
à tous du fond le voyons maintenant tu
bouffes enfin annoncé un peuple autres
ça non on va tester vraiment loin tu
arrêtes tout l'état ont cédé 5 se
dessine dans sa fougue par londres a
peut-être arrêter un monde enfin j'veux
pas les marcheurs blanc sévère très très
fort aussi
marès pas un truc sermonné tu as cannes
tout fait ce truc ça va c'est quand même
emprise qu'enfin je peux te dire que
maxime il te dirai c'est gratuit andré
fait offrir des fonds skoll pas de
chance coffret terre non mais là comme
on vient de le prendre quand je pense un
financement de bourses ou truc de fou
des six intermédiaire
les plus j'ai deux foulées 6 g dames g2o
qu'elle allait reprendre mon à nantes
on a vu pire quoi la mairie est bien là
il s'est remis dedans pas bijoux vite ou
bailleurs en fait s'il fait pas le
mauvais prêts vous tout à l'heure
celle-ci dominé la partie d'avant aussi
enfin je crois non c'est beau style
bouchons soit plus clair mais là c'est
dur mais le caté c3 qui traîne
maintenant serait très mal si c'est faux
[Musique]
le 5 est dur à défendre parce qu'en fait
on n'est ce pas que 5e mais surtout fou
prend 1,5
à bien jouer c'est pas clair du tout fab
sur le front de metron passer ça va très
bien en fait t'as du cailly c5 un jour
là au nom d'allah à toutes jambes et
that it à 0
mais il va peut-être la gagne la ceni
avait pas prendre ces 5 puisqu'il ya des
qui part et peut-être foule cinq échecs
et tour prend ses aises
maintenant il a raté donc ça va mais bon
ça soit enfin nul si ces gens bacon qui
étrange près de 6 ans et 4 ans oui qui
réussit à jouer vite quand même le
castro cordages
c'est génial il se bat à fond quoi pied
nul normal agence oui il est content
quand ça lui fait ouais mais lui se
mettant dans la peau du bas rhin
non ses pertes au quotidien
avec laurent vérat je crois que 4 et 5
je dirais que c'est quand même toujours
nul n'attend il fait tourner il t'en ben
partie jusqu'à la façade arrondie du
match qualificatif peut-être tentés à
3,5 selon ces mêmes tons que manger
quatre peut être un peu chiant à
défendre avec peu de temps il est
fougueux la jouer soft sur juste nul
exceptions près j'ai envie de te dire
c'est anecdotique
ouais pas vrai parce qu'ils y vont comme
il va peut-être marre il se dit oui je
ne veux qu'une partie plus intéressant
et je passais combien de temps quelques
heures cette partie c'est une éternité
quoi la salle 201 coups donc fait déjà
sans seconde fois de 200 secondes et un
monde plus puissants 20 secondes ou
trois cent vingt secondes et puis c'est
un peu de la ghetto à mon avis tu pars
on dira à 6 minutes quoi le but le plus
long de l'histoire
ric rac la star mais sa leçon de phu my
100f couvent et aura été long et
victoire du oui donc là qui reprend à
leurs huit points est assez fou un peu
non parce que si l'on vient
bon on en use de tweets c'est ce que je
fais une belle carrière
une petite carrière il a fait 21 light
c'est nous qui l'avons laïque et quoi
brest rennes et lille ira se tenir
pendant le live
heureusement qu'on a trouvé ça tu vois
c'est un peut égayer le la fin de match
quoi sinon c'est un peu longuet pour
dire la vérité à truc c'est sam etiassé
cesser enfin on se répète mais jure
c'est comme si au foot tu es mené 10 0
après dix minutes de jeu s'arrête quand
même jamais ne serait-ce pas comme 80
minutes à jouer enfin chez rocard ou qui
y fait rougir va détruire oui bah si tu
donnes la marne aussi permis je pense
sur un vrai chic et sephiroth la crise
pourrait détruire mais là oui je pense
pareil
on va distribuer le match il a fool mais
du coup ils caron stream un geste comme
ils ont un truc officiel stream mais il
est vraiment en train de ce crime et ça
en direct
je ne sais pas en fait si ce n'est pas
un stream officiel quoi tu aurais tu
aurais sûrement fermée un moment donné
j'aurais passé mais jusqu'au bout il ya
je les regarde et je deviens gelé dans
le flou et arrière fuyant jeu quoi je
fous le ski mais encore parce qu'à la
fin juin le match est cuit depuis depuis
belle lurette
il va te faire taper des 5
il va la perdre cabello 7-6 8/6 en tout
il va pas la perdre je pense un extrême
encore le match mais c'est fou en fait
la halle et cheval c'est pas du tout
match que tu as envie de se priver voyez
faire d'autres non mais ça m'amuse je
sais pas jusqu'à un certain score en
fait ça va mais là il ya le match est
plié quoi j'ai mis cas où il est c'est
génial
au côté du kiosque à j'adore sûreté sur
sera menacé de mort les joueurs
passaient j'ai pas éclater la connexion
au saint piat pas si mal les connexions
non voilà oui ça va tout à l'heure il y
avait il ya vingt ans était dans le dur
c'est vrai je suis fou et en affichage
et cie ce matin par l'ons ok mais
l'aurait quitté justice même offrir
mais bon ça aurait été marrant de se
prendre ce match belliqueux selon amath
avec un cavalier 4 il arrive que cet
hymne en russie attention la vie sous en
fait ils prendront quand même bien on
peut hélas très clément l'a fait si tu
fais cavailles f4s que la foudre lors
opposer à la gagne vu que j'ai en
réussite bloqués parfois de cinq nuls
pour ben pour le pas très fair empreinte
cinq voitures à rien si ce best of non
même le 1-0 et dur ouais il repassa il
repasse à +9 fab
quel match catastrophique quand même
pour vendre forest gérant le meilleur eu
le meilleur aura été le début faveur
ouais les premières parties
le reste du match il aura été assez
insipide
j'espère que demain le match tarde à
damas goût mais bon ce sera plus serré
normalement lors d une question de
ludwig est ce que quand tu veux qu'on te
donne ne pas en gros 10 12 il y aura
quand même les arénas le soir
normalement oui censée pointer dans sur
et ça dépend ça peut être des arenas
avait la preuve c'est que j'ai remonté
le classement à 27,90 quoi et du coup
c'est relou ce que je suis là rien à
regretter je repère de 50 points tu vois
pas ces choses moins de 27 90 sur reach
est comme neuf
c'est sur ces pistes sensiblement le
héros de oui en fait tu attends que vous
les guillen qui demande qui tient mieux
le match demain soir ce qui peut même
aller encore une calèche de moi c'est
bien joué ça mais pour détruire un peu
de les abris du roi ouais enfin je vais
faire pareil à call of london segat way
madame ses caprices prise prix g6 y
avait six qui traînent encore dans le
registre son geste sur angers 7 ok je
prends est ok ouais bah c'est juste pour
des monnaies comme je veux terriblement
moins bon je peins j'existe encore un
peu
non mais tu as raison c'est bien vrai
cette a4 maintenant
mais sacrifiées dessus et quand c'est
lui qui après lies hebbdaj de ce mois ci
et si le premier simple le premier mardi
du mois en fait y'a quoi title tuesday
mais c'est toujours au canon bah oui
mais ça fait que quatre ans peut-être
que c'est toujours le cas tu ne sais pas
tom des trois meilleurs joueurs ou pas
d'ailleurs
oui mais au moins ces épisodes pour ce
match tombe et 2 plutôt que c'est un
homme
c'est pas parce que pratiquent ce genre
de défaite qui sera une médiation peut
permettre le sport est un meilleur
mental
non je pense ça change absolument rien
fait ce genre de match faisant rage sur
internet et je le prenne pas trop
sérieusement de toute façon en c1 c'est
aussi sa clique c'est pas vraiment une
compétition officielle officiel ses
semis amical exhibition c'est pour ça
que c'est aussi dommage que ça tourne
comme ça
du coup tu perds le plaisir sa surface
frappe voiture en suggère c'est comme si
un match exhibition tu forcé à jouer
enfin on est toujours sur le même
principe quoi mais c'est là pour être du
spectacle pour être marrant c'est pas là
pour pourvoir un mec se faire défoncer
maison gens surtout dans un truc qui
parlera officielle n'est pas prendre
cette la fête retour 8 machin oif tout
est possible ouais du coup assez c'est
vraiment quand on voit des beaux matches
c'est vraiment bien mais voila ca
séquence quand on fait des matches longs
comme ça c'est dommage trouve que ça
nuit à la compétition personnellement
presque mon avis personnel ça n'engage
que moi on sait plus trop quoi dire
commentateur non mais du coup est ce que
tu as vraiment envie de regarder le
match demain soir après
vu sa wii / f1 c'est sympa il demain il
peut y avoir vraiment beau match donc
c'est cool mais jean tu vois tu aux
couleurs qui par sa tenue yal'envie
peut-être tu te dis bon demain je
n'allume pas l'ordi pour regarder hier
enfin je sais pas en fait je me dis les
fans soit je veux j'ai envie de
reprendre l'expression de blanes que
c'est pire que rien ou pas le message
fut rien et mieux tu as eu l'air brown a
été ramené un beau twitch quoi ça ouais
on est amis de vos tweets on a sauvé le
truc mais sinon enfin un joueur sur le
contenu du match est ce qu'à un moment
donné en fait ce qu'on a vu c'était pire
que rien mais c'est une question
philosophique l'en croire c'est que la
question pour scolariser ou papa peut
mettre un hashtag lille répondre à des
questions très ce que c'est vrai qu'à un
moment donné face et justin massa et les
deux joueurs ont commencé à mal jouer
stanislas haut niveau je pense que s'ils
peuvent écraser il écrase semi amical ou
pas ouais en fait faf fassara quoi au
final pas par là oui il a vraiment pas
fait d'efforts pour gagner avec un gros
écart
honnêtement non femmes j'ai trouvé quoi
il avait même un peu baissé le niveau on
a peut-être qu'il peut y avoir un truc
quand le mec comme une réalité genre
dont par la knvb 5 qui conduisent les
matchs rica où il essaie d'être le plus
il espère gagner
c'est notre avis on n'a pas forcément la
science infuse avec pas non plus un nom
mais 8 sur la semaine une heure et demie
qui a plus ou moins le même score
bon le truc c'est qu'on peut pas savoir
à l'avancé c'est un mauvais match mais
bon cela évidemment sont à quai quand
même il va georges fort que l'autre
c'est pas que je sous le sens et avec 27
51 2600 c'est énorme a dit non c'est
comme ça en fait ben c'est comme si si
moi je faisais un match contre un mec
qui quasiment 1700 contre vlad par
exemple bon ce doute qui est vivante au
niveau que je peux te faire illusion un
moment sur trois heures je vois là un
moment en fait ouais c'est ça c'est
qu'en fait je me rappelle avoir touché
suivi de match qui a été complètement
son fiston bullet porte niki caro qui
était en trois sets gagnants et en fait
je rappelle que ça donnait pas du tout
le même effet je crois que le score
c'était 6 2 6 1 6 3 quelque chose comme
ça mais je sais pas à chaque début de
set au deuxième set j'ai pas y avait 1-1
du coup tu étais un peu chaud beau on
april a perdu le set et puis troisième
set et peut-être de 1 pour pornic où il
s'est quand même fait écraser mais en
fait à chaque début de set avait un
nouveau toit madame machin
[Musique]
voilà c'est un peu le cas vendre du
match du jour de nadal contre qui trois
sets zéro facile 1,7 déjà 7 5 6 4 6 2 je
peux pas mais bon quand il servait pour
le set à 6 5 dans le premier il trois
balles de débreak dans vulgaire battu
vivre un peu bon en deuxième set il a
conseillé le set par break mais 0,40 à
peut-être l'aube ce débreak selon un
sacré petit vivre ans photo montrant un
chouille wayne on met ça en fait c'est
comme les petits coups d'intérêt par ci
par là c'est que sur un match un peu
comme celui là sur la dernière heure et
demie tu as deux trois petits moments tu
tiens si on gagne c'est la tête ça le
relance dans le match koala en fait
depuis relancé puisque même si l'on
gagne tout d'affilée ça change j'en
reparle en plein quand il avait gagné
les deux trois d'affilée là il y en
avait trois d'affilée je crois je
m'adapte être célébrés de 7 031 pour os
x d'un coût de 7 043 tu dis que tu as
dit que après je sais pas quand c'est un
peu le match raonic paye un tadjik m53
raonic n'ont que 2 0 milliards 5,4 à aux
niches service à suivre de 7,0 niche
c'est fabriquer qu'une fois du match
quoi oui il s'est braqué une fois par
match même pas des fois c'est quand même
plus gros serveurs du circuit tout est
enfin en fait il se fait débreaké puis
après celle au tig à nos matches mais il
ya des raisons pour lesquelles tu vivant
mêlant ce match s a jamais personne le
plus gros écart qu étaient remontés ces
+4 par l'agglo et c'est la première fois
qu'il ya que +4 était remonté en 60
matchs de pitch est ce qu en fait à plus
5 en fait je sais pas tu as peut-être
300 de galles a dû remonter là surtout
avec l'écart de niveau est plus sain
qu'on l'a eue après après une heure de
jeu mais il ya encore deux heures trente
de jeu c'est quand même fin par donc je
me répèterai jamais assez sur ce truc là
et ça va pas changer ça changera mais je
la fais des feedbacks j'ai fait tout ce
que j'ai pu c'est c'est un vrai ça c'est
un vrai problème en fait alors il a
répondu que c'était pas vrai tournoi
mais bon enfin il appelle les vrais
touristes il va plaider restera le truc
de l'abbaye c'est un truc complètement
amical c'est un vrai tournoi non mais en
fait peu importe mais où il n'existait
pas un vrai tournant la vie coûte qui
suis-je twitter dans l'année 20 minutes
il vit il aux aguets la faille c'est
quand même pris hier un chèque sphinx
est un fake news crois pas non plus on a
raison c'est évident
c'est vérifiable
non mais là on est pour le oui le
jugement condamnatoire non on a vraiment
raison c'est un vrai tournoi ça compte
vraiment pour le vélo c'est pas un truc
que pour les couleurs ça compterait pas
pour le lou ça veut dire non mais
globalement face et si c'est vrai mais
[Musique]
ni ok l'abbaye aussi alors enfin d'un
baiser par rapport aux tournois qu'il a
compté en fait du coup c'est vrai voilà
dans notre comptage qu'on a fait avec
fabre auront-elles on a coûté 7 seront à
l'affiché
bon ben oui lucho en comptant en
comptant le match pour le titre de
champion du monde et en comptant la
somme que phil woolas fini premiers
ex-aequo du coup ça faisait sept
d'affilée et ça c est ces séries en
cours du coup ses encours de toi qui l'a
pas gagné en ont en fait c'est bienne
l'an dernier donc en fait la vraie série
c'est cet encours et sort l'a fait avec
fin avec fable faut compter que je
préside et une victoire parce que ça
coûte combien tournoi mais ça compte
oui mais bon du coup on fait notre
calcul avec 7 il est plus juste que son
calcul avec 8 ouais bah ça c'est sûr et
donc oui on sait que le film l'an
dernier en fait ce serait sous mes yeux
trois joueurs ex-aequo c'était bus à
rognan et caruana il avait refusé de
l'aider en fait l'argument est mal fait
pour les départage à deux joueurs c'est
normal ils vont jouer en match à trois
oui un truc chelou bon 10h05 règlement
mais c'est comme ça et à les refuser en
fait le travail devant lui mais bon il
ya 30 les donc son coût du monde et ça
ça fait 7
et ça c'est le vrai comptage en fait ces
contacts seigneur fab
oasis c'est quoi elle un truc une nuit
ou deux max 2 eh bien on le score est
pas si charge sur le fait sur le
scénario nettement je pense iway avait
voulu si ça avait été un un méchant il
aurait pu faire pierre carous je crois
qu'ici les gens sont sympas
non mais en vo iata xavier claude tu
finis un peu par inertie 1
un peu comme subi ces surfaces comme
juste comme ça pour vendre fort est
quand même en pire
il a passé un tour il s'agit de
l'affairé personne tu as tu prends h3
ton pis bon peuple ce qui est un point
ça tout de suite ils veulent te reproche
coûte
sa part match sera dans les annales non
et on n'a pas une annonce avec toi cette
année l'intrus daria c'est mon chouchou
contre moroni ouais et j'ai déconné et à
20,3 et c'était ce vague n'a pas eu de
bol ça y est le gros match et quelques
beaux matches
bah jean xxiii star et on s'était bien
de la partie j'ai des trucs comme ça
mais peut-être dont le speech est ce top
level mais j'avais annoncé en plus à la
fin du du vent deux fois oscarisée avait
dit que les niveaux de jeu paraît assez
faible c'est dur ça va être difficile
contre ouvrirait j'avais dit que
normalement mais bon j'étais pas au
courant des poils de confection du cou à
cette époque là mais à mais oui j'ai vu
que là où il n'y a pas eu froid et de
connexions c'était sûr que ça finirait
comme ça
ah mais oui je suis étonné quelques
morceaux fait enfin 5 les ifi pas très
amusant on y met quand même plus c'est
john tembo
mais c'est pas très impressionnant mais
après quand il était le grand duché ce
tour est hyper impressionnant date il
est bon quoi bon je sais pas ce qu'il a
plus de mal sur internet que oui il est
pas du tout à fond ou je sais pas mais
ça à voir les gens qui te disent que
cheyrou déjà comme d'accueil gros
favoris banache vatant accueillent alors
oui mais pas trinquer 27-20 lautier 26
oui sur ce qu'on voit là mais bon firoud
déjà contre alcantara il n'a pas été
virevoltant non plus à mêmes hier contre
ces viandes
il a battu en bullet mais ok ouais ok
peut-être parce qu'aller bull est
content ouais c'est bien ici non non il
s'est bien battue comme en appel puis du
score final mais auquel on voyait aussi
rouge à deviner un petit peu tout le
match mais tu vois c'était pas face à
soi c'est le genre de match qui aurait
pu théoriquement tournée tu vois je sais
pas
une bonne chance pour support le bas
du coup il ya peut-être enfin peut-être
que la chance était égal du coup sur le
match d'hier mais oui tu te dis que si
ses liens avec la réussite ça aurait pu
un moment donné tournée n'était pas
ridicule s'accrochait bien j'ai rarement
entendu
tu sentais que ça pouvait adapter 3
c'est bien vu mais c'est pas fini
non ce que bon je passais mes bons repas
veulent garder je joue et ça quel
message leur échec échec échec ouais
c'est une chance et c'est alors la
finale de carling cup
mais il ya tant il a à tour 2e avec le
rock ou peu c'est un très mauvais sort
mais comment tu le découvres tu vécu
plus loin tu attends moi mais j'ai 5 h 5
alc et c'est bien triste si vous m leroy
dans le trou ouais c'est très beau fin
du secondaire
c'est nul ça je fais chaque achat qu à
chaque échec et tu n'en petit gars leur
assure un quatrième bouquet est en fait
un truc chez lui en suisse a pu faire
l'hélicoptère plus quoi aurais tu peux
te planter qu'avec les noirs
je sais fr cours f3 ou qu'il rachètera
taton g4
tu vas faire trois ou quatre toiles
fille est roi à voir venir contre le
pion à y sera la dernière brasil va être
content quoi
attention attention à être mangés cette
aune on a perdu
il va perdre assez horrible et karelia
aux îles aph et nab
c'est fou quoi et l'or aux jo queen
bienfaits suffit juste de faire halte
sur le clavier s'enlève l'auto queen la
tâche est ça fait marrer c'est pas vrai
faut faire acte lâche et dont je ne
doutais qu'il y avait un moyen de faire
mais bon bah écoute sa fille sur une
pelle sur une belle image au moins dix
tenues de gaza c'est à dire la exact bon
bah super wes brown monde me voit
peut-être que je serai là je sais pas on
verra
ouais possible si tu seras pour la
finale en fait bon je serai bon final
tendu la finale à da ba écoute et de
menthe avec vlad alors que le match
normalement si son voile arrive bien
j'espère avec tomates et puis rubin
joints tu peux toujours me contacter -
journée bien sûr et puis et de toute
façon je vais renvoyer tu servette sur
la chaîne officielle ces gens veulent
voir les interviews
najwa le plein de spectateurs qui ont
joui l'arrêt des violences et la reine
et puis un bep puis repartir et ouais tu
perds et tu parles fat duck ou merci
d'avancé